Hamas has published videos of their
Fighters holding Israeli children
implicitly explicitly saying that
they've got hostages now reportedly in
the video they say they don't kill kids
but that's not really the point the
point is they're basically sending a
warning to Israel they're making a
statement that if they're targeted there
are children of their victims children
being victims as well with them and it
is absolutely horrifying a new report
from Reuters says that uh essentially
the US must be prepared for World War
III I'm not I'm I'm I kid you not
they're talking about a security
analysis but we'll we'll we'll talk
about that plus we have scenes from all
the protests that have occurred today
nothing uh um I I would say Grand scale
absolutely crazy happening today of
course everyone's kind of relieved but
there were some incidents that had had
it happen I I some disturbing videos
which would we'll we we'll get into all
that but uh we're going to be talking
about what's the current state of what's
happening with obviously uh protest in
the US leftist support for uh BLM and uh
Palestine we have uh the view claiming
Hamas is like the proud boys despite the
fact that black lives matter is overtly
supporting them so we will talk about
these absurdities before we get started
my friends head over to Smith Creek
Farmstead do store they are proud
members of
timcast.net and some other things but
they got goats milk soap so if you want
to buy soap from somebody who actually
supports your values they are on Public
Square and you can go to Smith Creek
Farmstead do store click the link in the
description below and you can pick up
some soap some beard bomm but more
importantly they have chickens and when
you go to the website you can look at
their chickens look at this guy Clyde
the walking mullet look at him that
handsome sob and you know anybody with
chickens is handsome and blanch a lady
there a rooster but uh you got to buy
their soap so shout out to Smith Creek
Farmstead they're members of Tim on
Fridays we shout out companies from our
members and I hope you guys support um
businesses that share our values and we
can engage in byy cots where we make
sure we're voting with our dollars and
supporting people who uh uh agree with
with American values you can also go to
timcast.net you know we'd love to get to
everybody but you can submit as members
in the Discord uh your business and then
on Fridays we shout them out so uh
support our work over at
timcast.net
here and um and I'm looking forward to
our conversation oh who are you what do
you do well I'm um I'm a writer I'm
speaker I make films documentary films
I'm now done well coming out with number
seven which is called police date and
it's in theaters October 23rd and 25th
and there's a virtual Premiere watching
from home on October 27th so that
website is policestate fm.net and uh
actually talks about a lot of very bad
things that have been happening in the
United States in the last few years very
quickly one by one our basic freedoms
put into Jeopardy right on thanks for
hanging out should be fun we got Carter
Banks hanging out what's up everyone uh
pleasure to be here big fan of yours
toes like I was saying earlier you're
partly responsible for my dark red
pilling so it's going to be awesome
having you on yeah what does duza mean
duza is a Portuguese name and the
Portuguese came to India this was going
back to the 16th century and they
converted a bunch of Indians to
Christianity and the Indians who
converted were originally Hindu took
Christian names so one of my ancestors
was obviously converted by probably by a
missionary named duza and so we became
duza wow it's awesome F good to see yeah
hello everyone Let's uh let's let's go
let's talk there's so much I want to
talk about tonight so let's get the
group involved there is a lot to go over
I'm surge.com ready when you are to
here's a story from the Daily Mail
sickening footage released by Hamas
shows terrorists holding Israeli
Toddlers and children during Saturday
Massacre which shocked the world
signning footage released by Hamas today
allegedly shows a terrorist holding
Israeli toddlers the video shows Hamas
members holding the youngsters as they
sit around a table one is seeing rocking
a prom as an infant cries others are
carrying the distressed children rocking
them and patting their backs the footage
was recorded during uh during as Hamas
gunmen carried out their Mass
infiltration of Israel last Saturday
according to Israeli newspaper the
Jerusalem Post the attack saw Hamas
prescribed as a terrorist organization
by the EU and the US burst through the
heavily militarized border around the
Gaza Strip This we all know took an
estimated 150 Israeli foreign and dual
Nationals uh National hostages back to
Gaza during its initial attack Hamas
said on Friday that 13 of them had been
killed in Israeli air strikes it has
previously said four hostages died in
the bombardments so you can see here
they have images of them taking the
children now I suppose the the claim
they're trying to make is that they
didn't kill the kids there's also videos
where Hamas Fighters are indiscriminate
firing into Porta poot so this is all
propaganda from a group that is out of
control sadistic targeting civilians if
if one if one Hamas guy or Palestinian
activist comes out and says that they
believe in peace it doesn't matter
because clearly there is no unified
message as to what they're doing they're
going and indiscriminately just killing
and capturing civilians and we know they
use them as bargaining chips so here we
are again in this uh in the circumstance
and and the craziest thing is right now
on the left the only only thing they're
saying is Israel's killing babies this
is it is this is the nightmare scenario
of War but I got to be completely honest
they will make that the left makes the
argument that Israel started it when
quite literally Hamas broke the barriers
down and went and started targeting
civilians so you know you want to take
this back thousands of years fine so be
it but Hamas is targeting civilians in
children Israel targeting militarized
sites or whatever is not the same thing
though we are all distressed when
civilians die that's that's a no-brainer
I mean what the Defenders of Hamas in
this country and the West are doing is
they're trying to dispute a wholesale
Truth by making sort of retail
objections and what I mean by that is
they'll say this particular image is
distorted or this is not a valid video
as if to say that and and maybe they're
right because we're in an age where
there's so much fog of War there's so
much confusion about whether this video
was digitally altered sometimes
difficult for you or I to know but the
implication is that if the video is
invalid kids are not being threatened by
Hamas and and I think we shouldn't lose
sight of that bigger truth sort of that
that video that picture of the burned
baby that uh Ben Shapiro posted
yesterday and then the AI machine said
hey it's actually fake and it's like yo
maybe it's real maybe it's fake it
doesn't matter it is real apparently now
but who knows if that's even true but It
ultimately it doesn't matter because
they did kill babies and very likely
burn them alive I don't know it doesn't
matter if that picture is real or fake
the these these videos of Hamas storming
these houses and then you can see one
guy lighting a house on fire yo they're
not checking the bedrooms to make sure
innocent people aren't dying they're
opening fire on closed porta potties
with people in them they don't care and
I should say it's very very
self-righteous me to say that they are I
it seems as if they are from reports
that I've read that they were
indiscriminately murdering old women
people bro there's there's videos like
look I just watched a video where
they're walking through the music
festival and there's a row of portal
potties and just go pop pop pop like
come on man there could be kids in there
there could be women when we see them in
one video waiting at the Gate of a Kuts
and then a car pulls up they wait for
the gate to open run up and execute the
people inside the car they're not
checking to see if that's an elderly
woman or not they're just opening fire
on the car and then running in they're
not checking to see if there's people in
the room they walk into the house and
then start setting things on fire
there's a so when we see photos that are
being published that don't show the
bodies they show blood and they show you
know Gore and stuff like that
I really don't think that the Israel
government is manufacturing scenes when
we can see the videos and we know that
even journalists of a more pro pro
Palestine event are saying yeah they
target civilians it's one of their
tactics I bet there's videos of them
holding children my guess is that
civilians are making fake content
governments are making fake content on
all sides but that also there's lots of
real content as well and it's terrifying
me cuz like I was saying earlier I I twe
I want to go look at the most gruesome
stuff where is that I want to see it and
then as I was thinking about it I was
like I don't I don't want to get tricked
into seeing gruesome stuff from 2 years
ago or things that like fake Gru
gruesome stuff that makes me crazy so I
don't even know if I want to look at any
of it now but I don't want to not know
what's going on so the the big
controversy the other day which
everybody get mads about gets mad about
you've got the the the you know very
pro-israeli side anger that anyone would
dare question the authenticity of this
photo posted by Israel you've got people
on the left arguing that it's not real
and if you're saying it is oh no you're
posting fake nonsense I don't about that
I care about actually investigating the
story and figure out who's lying now
what had happened was we I did an AI or
not analysis on the photo that was
posted by the Israeli Prime Minister and
Ben Shapiro had posted the same image
and it said it was AI I then put an AI
generated image in it said it was AI I
then put in a graphic designed by humans
it said it was made by humans we I then
put in a photograph of John fedman that
we got from a news story we used for a
thumbnail and it said it was a real it
was a human generated photo so it was
accurate I don't know if the the photo
of the baby in this regard was uh or I I
should say definitively right now it was
inaccurate as it pertained to that the
charred remains of that of that baby uh
there has been a much deeper analysis
where they actually posted the forensic
analysis of the image and the manip
other manipulations that were made to it
it appears to be Beyond A Reasonable
Doubt the photo is real it is a is a
real photo of a real doctor showing the
remains and uh it's it's kind of
horrifying that this this is what
happens first it's horrifying that
people are like I demand to see the
photo to prove it
and that's that's sad and that's
horrifying at first they're like look
for privacy reasons we we don't want to
show these things but people demand the
proof so it gets posted and then what
happens is propagandists and people
trying to
to I guess win a win win an information
War then claim it's all fake and then
finally we get a bunch of different AI
forensic analysis one of the things they
did was there's some tools where it
shows you uh uh like pixel patterns and
like things like that that you can't see
with your own eyes but when you run it
through some several filters you can
clearly see lines where AI is generated
the original image doesn't appear to be
fake and then there are faked versions
of it that are clearly fake so I I would
just say at this point who knows I
believe to the best of our abilities
it's it's a legit photo and this is stff
horrifying but again I don't I don't
think we need at this point when there's
videos of Hamas laughing holding the
kids they're clearly terrorist Mo has
not changed if you go back to the um
'70s when you had the IRA and you had
the you know the um incident at anbi and
so on the the idea of taking hostages
the idea of exploiting the other side's
reverence for human life I mean think
about it they know that the Israelis
care about human life if the Israelis
really didn't care the hostages would be
meaningless the reason that they grab
your kid as a hostage is they know that
you're going to go okay you know I'm
going to so so it reminds me a little
bit how in this country you know they
use the accusation of racism I'm not
think of this this just by by way of
analogy when somebody comes to you and
says you're a
racist their hidden assumption is that
you're not a racist because if you were
really a racist you'd be like thank you
very much this is awesome you know what
it's like someone coming to me go Jes
you're Indian I'd be like yeah sure but
they want you to go no I'm not so the
fact that you go no I'm not is you don't
believe you are and you don't want to
think of yourself as a racist so the
charge of racism only works on
anti-racists not anti-racist though they
they they that phrase anti-racist to
them it works on people who are not
racist exactly yeah because it because
it hits them where it hurts if if
someone was genuinely racist and proud
of it it would not hurt at all they
would take it as a compliment this is
this this is a very clever game they
play they've TR they they took the
phrase anti-racist because people assume
it means you oppose racism it doesn't
anti-racist means you're quite literally
racist but in a different
way that's a good point they've that's
right this this appropriation of
vocabulary and the left is really good
at this I mean the resistance you know
the uh even the language of
decolonization I mean decolonization is
a good idea right I mean I'm from India
India was a colony of the British if you
say
decolonization but over the years the
Indians have sort of reassessed because
they've now realized yeah there were
some bad things from the British but
guess what you know we still wear suits
we still have British laws we still have
parliamentary systems of government we
got a lot of things from the British so
uh but but nevertheless this this strope
of anti-colonialism is driving this
whole narrative that's what makes the
Palestinians into Heroes and the
Israelis into villains how Bloody was
the uh Indian Revolution if it was even
considered a revolution against the
British When They seized control it was
one of the UN bloodiest Revolutions of
all because Gandhi recognized that the
Indians were they outnumbered the
British were ruling India with a very
small contingent of people and so Gandhi
realized listen all we need to do is
sort of
paralyzed the country with nonviolent
demonstrations and it'll be too
difficult for the British to kind of
manage this Indian elephant and so the
British sort of essentially Let It Go
and but again the the only reason the
Indians could pull that off is because
the British were not Hitler I mean if
the British were Hitler Gandhi would be
you know a
lampshade God
literally but the Indians could count on
the fact that they could go light on the
tracks the railway tracks and all the
British trains would go they grind to a
halt because again the British are not
willing to run over Indian kids uh and
so that ultimate the British their own
morality was the undoing of the Empire
wow and I think we're seeing the very in
the United States elements of the the
Liberals and the left that are
anti-america and hate this country
there's a video right now going around
of someone on I think it's on Fox I'm
not sure where they're asking a person
at this one of these protests in New
York supporting Hamas saying you know do
you believe America should take care of
itself first I'm like absolutely not and
it's like okay well when you have a
large faction of Americans maybe half
the country who are like America last
okay well you've got problems with pipes
in Flint or Newark or whatever insert
country but you want to send our money
overseas first this country will not
survive that it's like you're you're
it's you're you're giving away your
money to your neighbors before paying
your rent eventually you get
evicted yeah sooner or later I me one of
the things I found then going back to my
just experience growing up was that
India had these wars with Pakistan and I
noticed that while those wars were going
on every Indian was on the Indian side
for the exact same reason that every
Indian backs the Indian side in the
cricket match you know nationalism India
first is taken for granted nobody even
debates it it's not like you have to
discuss is it a good idea to be India
first I mean no Indian would even know
what that means uh and And yet when I
came to the United States suddenly I
realized and this this is in some way a
legacy of the Vietnam War suddenly I
realized a lot of Americans actually are
not on the American side they actually
want the Vietnamese to win they are
America last and they see America as a
villainous force in the world even
though America's been a very benign
force in the world any other country
that had this kind of power that the US
has had since World War II would have
used it far more tyrannically oh yeah
definely it's almost like a tell when
you when someone says that the US is
like the most racist country in the
world I hear all time like you have not
traveled anywhere quite literally like
the least racist country like even I
bring this up when I went to Sweden they
try to claim they're very Progressive
but they're super racist they're like we
we we we scut all the poor people into
these ghettos and then tell everyone how
how awesome we are but then we only hire
white Natives and in the United States
you've got white liberals without group
preference and there was a story that
came out that found I think over the
past several years something like 90
plus percent of mid to high level jobs
were all given to non-white individuals
because of the Dei push so it's like
like that's clearly racist and in
violation of the 1964 Civil Rights Act
but here we are Let's uh let's jump to
the story I hope you all are ready it
may have been the global day of jihad
Friday the 13th but we have this from
Reuters us must be ready for
simultaneous Wars with China and Russia
report says the US must prepare for
possible Wars with Russia and China by
expanding its conventional forces
strengthening alliances and enhancing
its nuclear weapon modernization program
a congressionally appointed body
partisan panel said on Thursday the
report from the Strategic posture
commission comes amid tensions with
China over Taiwan and other issues of
and worsening frictions with Russia over
its invasion of Ukraine another thing
that many people have brought up to us
that came up yesterday was something
called the Samson option considering the
conflict with what's going on with
Israel I think it's particularly
relevant to this story for those who
aren't familiar the Samson option is the
name that some military analysts and
authors have given to Israel's deterrent
strategy of massive retaliation with
nuclear weapons as a last Resort against
a country whose military has invaded
Andor destroyed much of Israel
commentators also have employed the term
to refer to situations where non-nuclear
non-israeli actors have threatened
Conventional Weapons retaliation such as
yaser aret now what's interesting about
that concept of the Samson option the
general idea being if this so we we have
this cono of Hamas storming in killing
civilians Israel then starts Target
targeting Hamas uh uh uh uh bases and
weapons Depots and things like this
civilians get caught in the crossfire
they die we then get fake videos a fake
video today apparently of cutter saying
that they were going to cut off gas
supply not real it's been debunked my
understanding but you have threats from
Iran you have Lindsey Graham saying war
with
Iran if there is an invasion of Israel
the fear is that they're just going to
say we we refuse to be destroyed and
they'll fire a nuke at their enemy but I
think the reality is any country with a
nuclear weapon that is invaded and is
facing extinction or or non-existence is
going to launch a nuclear weapon so the
fear here is Israel being particularly
vulnerable if they launch a nuke then
what happens I mean it's going to be all
out World War III massive nuclear
warfare yeah I mean when I think about
it the Samson option was essentially the
core of what in the Cold War we called
mutually assured destruction because
mutually assured destruction is the
United States has 10,000 nuclear
warheads and the Soviet Union has 10,000
nuclear warheads and the reason you have
peace is each side makes a public
declaration that if the other side
launches nukes you will do the same and
cause essentially the extinction of
mankind and it's that Mutual fear oddly
enough that keeps both parties
reasonably well behaved now we're in a
postc Cold War era of course but I don't
see why that logic disappears it remains
actually identical except now it has to
be applied you know more regionally or
more locally but why would a country
allow its own Extinction without wanting
to visit exactly the same on the the
people who perpetrated that I mean this
is a case where I mean I suppose there a
certain at a certain theoretical level
you could well listen they've already
launched these nukes I'm going to die
anyway why should I kill more people I
just need to sit tight and let myself be
blown up but that's not realistic no one
really thinks like that yeah I mean I I
don't know I've never been through
nuclear war but I it's not just like the
nuke hits and then that's the end like a
nuke will set up the stage for an
invasion Like You Can level the ground
level all the defensive capabilities and
then invade the the city that got nuked
like two days later or something or a
day later also there's Fallout for
there's all sorts of things that happen
afterwards that also suck if you don't
die immediately it's almost worse
radiation and 48 Hours of Fallout or
something did the Chinese are they
actually uh genetically altering their
soldiers to be radiation resistant we
talked about that there was a report
that they're they've started breeding
genetic super soldiers I mean that's a
scary reality of what's to come and so I
I suppose the concern is not even
nuclear weapons I think that's old
school thinking it is it honestly it is
actually crazy to me that most people to
this day are like nuclear weapons I'm
like bro that's a hundred years old
basically like they started developing
this stuff 100 years ago deployed a
couple by today standards weak ones
that's kind of scary to think too yeah
and then really I mean what since the
70s we've had icbms and and mvs and
things like this the US 10 years ago uh
uh funded the the a very very small
Megaton Gravity Bomb basically pocket
size version of the fat man and uh we
also have these icbms have hypersonics
but I think people need to understand
that a lot of the research has been in
targeted biological weapons and the real
scary thought is not that Israel says
we're going to fire a nuke but that
they're like we're going to unleash a
virus or something like that or like an
insect plague I think they people have
been using insects also I mean think
let's let's think about this
realistically you've got ethnic conflict
in the Middle East right these are
groups that hate each other based on
their ethnic heritage
wouldn't they be specifically trying to
Target if if if you've got groups of
people saying that they want to
eradicate is Israel would they not make
weapons specifically to do so if they
had the capabilities they probably would
I I I do believe that it's more about
territory and less about genetics at at
the core I think it's about who owns
that area of the world well right right
but what I'm saying is the majority of
the people in Israel are Jewish and many
of these people in say Iran or in Gaza
Lebanon explicitly say the Jewish people
and so it's not even about that I mean
isn't there on all sides when it comes
to any kind of War if the US is facing
war with Russia there is there is an
incentive be This Is War man I mean you
you look at what uh uh what what what
was that Japanese unit in World War II
731 I think 731 731 they stuck people's
arms into Sub-Zero temperatures they're
in a room they put their arm into a vet
or whatever with subzero temperatures
and then pull it out and shatter it with
a hammer to see what would happen yeah
then after the war the US is like we
need those guys over here like theity we
did cuz they were sending like plague
fleas and hot air balloons over here I
think one actually landed well they were
doing those bombs yeah they had the they
had the hot air balloons what are they
called I weed about yeah we did and they
would float in the jet stream Y and then
once they would start sinking once they
got too low then a bag would drop and it
would go back up crazy and then it would
dropping bombs y I mean we just get a
small insight into how nuts these people
are just when we think about gain of
function research I mean just think of
something so explosive as to take highly
contagious viruses and start screwing
with them to make them more lethal to
quote study them and this is going on in
Laboratories all over the world and the
probability of these viruses getting out
when you add up all the Laboratories and
all the procedures is actually pretty
high so it ends up that you create a
worse plague than you started or that
you started out to try to diffuse
and and all of this is this is all in
peace time and now you put in you put in
war and the aggression and the
competitiveness of War and the massive
resources devoted to the military which
is much bigger than the resources
available to the NIH and you can only
imagine what scary stuff is going on
there yeah yeah and and honestly it's
beyond just uh uh biological weapons or
directed energy weapons when the US
during the Manhattan Project nobody knew
what they were doing they were they were
speculating that the US was working on
some kind of technology and uh some of
the speculation was a a laser beam a
death a death ray and and some people I
I believe did speculate that there was
going to be a nuclear bomb I think it
was because the the initial publications
of nuclear reactions quantum mechanics
and things like that was like 20 some OD
years earlier so the US started working
on this and theoretically saying like
can we make this explode can we blow it
up big and so people were trying to
figure out what it was right now but no
one knew that's my point right now the
weapons the US has are probably beyond
our comprehension right or I shouldn't
say beyond our comprehension I mean like
we said we be like oh wow they did what
it's just
that if they I put this way I bet they
could come out and be like yes the large
you know International multinational
military industrial complex corporations
have a weapon that is based on you know
X you'd be like wow I never thought of
that you might I might say that there
are the weapons that are being used now
are beyond our perception that might be
that might be an interesting way to look
at it because like lasers you don't see
them they're just heat it's just heat
that you can't see what I mean is like
we're not even thinking of what they've
already developed so we're talking about
like biological weapons and like that
was 20 years molecular disassembly
through vibration I mean skin just fall
off just by hitting them with a low
frequency stuff like that or just like
renders you not able to think at all
look at the the the was it the Havana
syndrome yeah Havana syndrome they
thought that was a weapon I guess
they're saying it's not now but people
would hear like a loud hum and then they
would lose they start losing vision in
one eye and getting headaches and they
couldn't think straight I mean
interestingly with every major war the
magnitude the scale the horrific nature
of it was completely unanticipated
Before the War I mean World War I nobody
had any idea that it would last as long
that trench warfare would you'd have
people who are basically fighting for 2
and a half years for like 50 yards of of
land uh and you're sitting in a trench
Knee Deep in water you sleep there uh
people are being shot up and their
bodies then just dissolve right next to
you and and so just the sheer horror of
it and and you know the thing about it
is we haven't had that kind of a war now
in all of our lifetimes cuz we have to
go back to World War II for a
comprehensive War so it makes people in
a sense lose sight of what war actually
means the first one first world war was
the machine gun no one anticipated the
machine gun so they'd get up with their
rifles and run towards what was
assumedly dudes with rifles as they had
done for thousands hundreds of years and
then the machine gun changed that and
then World War II you have air air power
like the the force of an air bomber
changes in everything and now what do we
have we have space lasers who knows what
we got this is the story well yeah China
does have space lasers not say they're
weaponized but we know for a fact that
story you could drop stuff from orbit
readily it's just getting it up there
getting it up there right but uh what
you're describing in is the story of
basically every war right so uh uh we've
talked about Gettysburg the Confederates
were using muzzle loaded uh rif rifled
muskets and the union had adopted breach
loading rifles with cartridges so the
union is firing every 10 seconds and the
Confederates are firing every 30 seconds
to a minute Napoleon I don't know if
Napoleon had new tech other than like if
the Dutch Tech that the Dutch didn't
have or tech tech that the the austrians
didn't have or whatever but he had he
invented the core system the core you
know the core military core where he'd
divide uh command amongst his generals
and give all of his Marshals basically
they were called uh total Authority
amongst themselves and so they were able
to move much more rapidly and and
respond Battlefield activity much more
fluently right right uh absolutely I
mean there's a there's a very
interesting uh study of Western
Civilization which stes to understand
how the West became the dominant world
power which it has been over the past
500 years and the argument was that the
Western countries were always fighting
and as a result each side had to keep
innovating in terms of warfare to get
the edge over the other guy whereas you
think of other take American Indian
societies for example now there was
tribal War fair and so on but it was
conducted kind of the same way whereas
what was happening in the west is one
guy you know you start off and everybody
you have a normal Cavalry then one guy
starts inventing a crossbow and the
other guy to develop a shield and then
the knights start putting on Armor and
so there's constant Innovation that
shows why the power in the west keeps
moving I mean it belongs to the
Portuguese in fact that's how the
Portuguese got to India they were the
leading power in the west at one time
then the Spanish then the French then
the English the Hitler's actually basic
point was he was kind of envious of the
fact that the British and the French had
sort of dominated the world in the
previous hundred years he's like what
about the Germans so a lot of Hitler's
aggression was motivated by that he
actually admired the British Empire he
wanted to create one well with Europe
you you have a peninsula and with with
expanding population density the
Mediterranean is is warm weather so
there was there was uh more abundant
food it was easier to grow food you end
up with people with more free time
then you get population density with
close proximity and conflict over
resources once winter starts rolling in
so you have all this fighting because
exactly as you described you get
Innovation there was one uh story I read
where I can't remember what battle it
was but uh one side made their arrows
with very tiny notches so that the when
they fired the arrow towards the enemy
the enemy could not put the knock or
whatever it's called the notch or knock
or whatever it's called into the string
and they couldn't fire it back but
theirs with the larger hole they could
pick up so they could use both arrows
but like that kind of innovation now
here's the thing about North America
sparsely populated when Native Americans
would fight it would be brutal but they
could also flee so we see this in
natural selection as well it's why uh
birds are less likely to be aggressive
because they can just leave flight and
in in the lit in the sense of like
avoiding a fight not in the literal
sense avoiding a fight takes less energy
than engaging in a fight so burrowing
animals tend to be more vicious and
flying animals tend to be less vicious
for that reason right it's not absolute
right rabbits are not particularly
vicious you back them in a corner they
might nip at you but goph might their
strategy was just to have lots of
themselves which is kind of funny or
their evolutionary pressure and they
didn't have armor the Native Americans
as far as I know I don't know think that
they they focus they didn't build
castles they didn't build defensive
bastions they didn't really that I know
of uh build armor and things like
protective cuz it was always like attack
and Retreat attack and flee and run away
a massive land mass with with tremendous
Farmland in the Great Plains that you
didn't have to have such uh uh dramatic
fighting over resources and uh
effectively you could leave if if they
were chased out and the land was taken
and by a Waring tribe they would run
away and they didn't I don't know I
assume that they didn't Farm not as
readily as they did in Europe uh they
were more hunter gatherers well you had
two types you had the sedentary farming
tribes and the the Hopi the Pueblo but
of course they were always the mercy of
the kamanche and the Apache and the
nomadic more vicious uh Tomahawk
carrying uh tribes which were which
would have their way uh with these other
I mean Columbus noticed this when he got
here he the first Indians that he ran
into were really nice guys and Columbus
went back to you know he went back to
Spain and he's like these people are
like they're like Adam and Eve they're
like living in the Garden of Eden the
second time he came back he he ran into
a whole different crew and he and and in
fact a lot of the Alle ation against
Columbus OH Columbus turned vicious and
so on well the reason he turned vicious
is he ran into tribes that were into
Mass Slaughter and uh that opened his
eyes this is the thing that the left
ignores when they were like uh uh the
the colonizers the European colonists
called the Native American Savages and
it's like no no no no no no no the
French cooperated with many of the
tribes in in the in the Canadian
territories fur Traders they got along
just fine the Aztecs however who are
pulling people down on altars and
ripping their body part organs out they
were a bit shocked by that we're shocked
about these hostages now think about
Cortez in Mexico seeing this stuff I
mean you have rivers of blood imagine
the psychological impact on the Spanish
and uh so yeah I think that is I'm
unsurprised the left takes the view that
the Aztecs were doing something
acceptable because sacrificing children
like literally just killing children
yeah would like any one of us would be
watching that happen would probably
start crying
and and you imagine Cortez the the the
the historical view from the left is
that Cortez is on this boat sailing to
to the America going
like and he's got like Devils behind him
like when really he's a European guy he
lands here and yes there's Conquest
involved they're Warriors they're
Fighters and then he comes upon children
being mutilated for no reason I wouldn't
be surprised if the if he started
balling his eyes out and then was like
we have to stop
this exactly no that's right um also you
mentioned interestingly about you know
Evolution and natural selection and
that's a interesting framework for
looking at human nature and warfare
because the premise of evolution is that
self- protection and self-interest is
the primary grounding of human behavior
and I think even ethical systems and
Christianity is no different you know
love thy neighbor like thyself right
okay it's assumed that you love yourself
if you didn't love yourself then the
whole thing makes no sense you have no
compass for deciding how to love your
neighbor whereas liberalism is I as far
as I know the only ideology in existence
that treats
self-interest by itself as something bad
and something to be guilty about and
apologetic about and they deploy it
selectively against the white man and
against the west and it and it is really
fascinating to me people really need to
snap themselves out of this the hatred
of profit the the Assumption the word
profit is something bad or means
something negative the left in this
country has really even gotten
conservatives feeling guilty about it it
is fasc we talked about this the leftist
gofundmes when they're like I'm raising
money for this don't worry we're taking
none of the money they do whenever they
do fundraisers are like don't worry the
money is only going here and we won't
take anything of it when I used to work
for for nonprofits they would we would
have uh uh our tax the tax filing for
nonprofit is a 990 and it would it would
uh the the organization organization
would say when you make a donation x
amount is Administrative x amount is to
the programs
and so people would actually ask you how
much of the money am I giving you is
going towards the program and legally
you're supposed to be like oh it's 20%
administrative CA and 80% to the cause
which makes literally no sense because
no one at the nonprofit is getting
ridiculous salaries even among the CEOs
at nonprofits they're getting
substantially less than corporate CEOs
though they sometimes like the big ones
they get millions of dollars for sure
you're running a massive organization
but I'm like I would tell people like my
guy all of your money is going towards
the cause now you want to give you the
tax filing amount I'll tell you but this
idea that we can't pay for the staff to
file the paperwork that we can't have a
have food to eat or pay our rent or buy
a car while we're doing this work is
absurd but that's the mentality people
have no you doing the work should do it
for free the left has really however
what however this emerged in this
country is crazy to me they've got
people being like profit is bad now I
think mostly conservatives are more
attuned to realizing that's BS we're
capitalists here and profit means your
cut of what you're worth the labor you
did but we people need to realize you're
allowed to make money my challenge is
greed you have charity and greed the The
Virtue and the sin and so I'm try not to
be greedy even though like some of my
closest advisers and friends are like
Ian now is the time for you to be greedy
make some money dude like and
I'm like I just it just you can't give
anything a lot of times a lot of times
these concepts of greed hypocrisy
they've lost their original meaning so
greed normally has meant historically uh
that you have your eye on something that
is not rightfully yours that's greed
greed is not I made an incredible
product lots of people wanted to buy it
and so they all gave me $10 a piece and
so now I'm a multi-millionaire that's
not greed that's you're supplying a want
and someone else is willingly giving you
the payment in there's no greed involved
take hypocrisy hypocrisy in its current
meaning is you have a moral standard and
you are falling short of it think of it
some guy who's like I'm a family man oh
he was seen you know with another woman
He's a hypocrite actually that has never
been the meaning of hypocrisy because
everyone is supposed to have higher
moral standards than you live up to
because otherwise the way to not be a
hypocrite is not to have any moral
standards at all then you can never be a
hypocrite because there are no standards
to be to judge you by right so hypocrisy
traditionally means I have a standard
but I don't really believe in it I'm a
faker so I actually I'm only pretending
to be a good guy but in fact I'm a
really bad guy so that guy's a hypocrite
because he's stating a value that he
doesn't really believe in but if someone
genuinely believes that you know I
should be charitable I should be a nice
guy I should be faithful to my wife but
guess what I'm not as charitable as I
ought to be hey my head turns when a
pretty girl goes by I'm not a hypocrite
I'm just falling short of worthy moral
standard is it if you accept that you're
falling short and don't try to try to
change it then you become
hypocritical no because uh because well
at least in Christianity you acknowledge
that you are falling short and you are
your job is to be aware of your falling
shortness and your job is to be aware
that you are um that you constantly need
to strive to do
better yeah I think that's often
heartful to gather or to to grasp I
should say rather it's uh it seems like
innately inhuman to like say the profit
is something to be bad but it's like cuz
normally in hunting You' get what you
need for an animal but you think about
it you're getting you're hunting the
animal you're getting not only food for
yourself but for your family for those
around you Etc that's what profit really
comes from underneath everything and
it's weird Tim's right that this is
taken roote in America but usu's part of
it is banking profit that they're taking
so much interest and it's unethical You
could argue that's the usurious part
they call it usury because it's
unethical unethical interest but um so
people are like see a lot of people
making profit I put it in quotes because
they're just sitting in their in their
luxury apartments getting 20% on every
loan that they've got out and you're
like yo that a you ain't doing anything
for that money bro you just born into
that that banking family yeah although
even that's very questionable because if
you think of money as money is the
stored value of your earlier labor right
so let's say for example I'm now 62
years old I've accumulated money all my
life I've worked really hard for it now
I could have spent it then and had
instant gratification but I chose
deferred gratification so now I have the
stored value and this there is a time
value of money right so now if I invest
that money I don't have to work but it
does represent work I've already done
that's how I got the money in the first
place now you're right when it becomes
generational and it's coming down from
family to family but you know one of the
remarkable things about the United
States is that in this country the vast
majority of people did not become rich
that way in in other countri it is true
that in Europe by and large you meet a
really rich guy chances are he's from a
rich family generational but in the
United States uh self-made people all
over the place and not to mention within
the same family I mean one guy's a
millionaire and another guy is like Pump
and Gas in the same family same you know
I mean think of it same gene pool same
socialization and they end up so
different in the in the in the Walk of
Life let's let's jump to the story from
Fox News we're going to expose Harvard
for the Liars they are GOP Harvard
graduates send scath letter blasting
school's response to Pro Hamas students
abhorent Harvard has faced heated
criticism after student groups expressed
support for Hamas after its attack on
Israel take a look at this tweet from
James Lindsay how it started and how
it's going it's a good one and the first
one is a quote despite being the most
acclaimed academic institution in the
country Harvard received a
0.00 point Free Speech ranking on 100
point scale a full 11 points behind the
next worst school and then the response
from the Harvard president over the uh
pramas protests our University Embraces
a commitment to free expression that
commitment extends even to views that
many of us find objectionable even
outrageous we do not punish or sanction
people for expressing such views that's
absolutely hilarious because they have
criticized and condemned conservatives
in the past yeah the fact that they're
unwilling to criticize this group and
they're actually saying well you know
they're allowed to do it shows Harvard
overtly supports what these students are
saying the institutions are absolutely
corrupted but as horrifying as this the
situation uh in Israel is we are now
seeing the left overtly supporting acts
of Terror killing of children capturing
and killing of civilians and uh I'm I I
appreciate their free speech I'm glad
they're saying the things they're saying
yeah I mean but and and and yet it is it
is so poignant for me to see liberals
liberals of the old stripe and here I'm
actually thinking of the former Harvard
president Larry Summers I don't know if
you saw his statement he's like
I'm so bitterly grieved that an
institution to which I have been
affiliated with for most of my adult
life is uh you know has has sort of
broken with the principles and and was
now taking the side of the terrorists
and I was thinking wow Larry Summers if
anyone would say who's the embodiment of
Harvard over the last 50 years they
would say you you're the example of the
kind of classical liberal that
surrendered to the left over the past
several that enabled the leftist
takeover of these institutions cuz
conservatives never ran these
institutions when I was a student at
Dartmouth I would say it was the old
line liberals who were in charge and the
new Left pushing up against them and the
change in the in the college to today
would be that that that Insurgent group
is now completely in charge and the old
line liberals have been pushed aside but
the old line liberals let it happen and
they're now in a sense living with the
fruit of it it's a little bit like some
of these women on the subway you know
these Bohemian women who are approached
by people who like punched them and
slapped them and you feel sorry for them
but you're like isn't this what you
voted for right you know if if this if
this this guy had come and slapped some
other woman and you saw it you'd be like
don't go after that guy he's a victim of
racism you know let's not black lives
matter so you've got this and they they
get hit and go help help I'm being
oppressed that's right when it happens
to them suddenly the rules change it's
like when Elon Musk banned like those
five journalists leftists on Twitter for
like one day not they go nuts I mean
they were quoting John Stewart Mill I
mean they were discovering the virtues
of Free Speech but only because it was
happening to them yeah yeah
so yeah and there in lies the big
challenge but now I mean some of them
stay true to their principles there's
that woman uh whose boyfriend was
murdered in front of her and the reports
are that she's refusing to identify the
murderer what but the conspiracy theory
on the on on on x/ Twitter is that it
was a hit yeah I heard that and it's
like you know I don't know about that
but I got to be honest are you really
going to come out and claim to the
police that the reason you're not not
identifying the Killer is because that
would be racist are the cops going to
believe that be like really someone
murdered your boyfriend in front of him
and you're like but if he goes to jail
it's racist so whoopsie so a lot of
people are convinced like there's no way
someone watches their loved one die in
front of them and then tell and then
says but because of racism I think the
killer should be free unless they wanted
it to happen I mean it's easier if
you're a journalist and you know the
suspect is black but you leave that fact
out of the article which we've been
seeing in recent decades but then at
least you are not facing the
consequences it's easy for it's it's
kind of virtue on the cheap I'm not
going to mention that he's black but you
know I get some virtue points but but
it's a whole another matter if somebody
comes and kills your kid and and and
you're facing and you're you're not
willing to say okay that guy did it this
in in the culture War a lot of uh uh
parents that we see waking up it's
because they're finally being impacted
by it and it's it's an unfortunate
reality many years ago Irving crystal
said that neoconservatism which we've
got a lot of problems with these days
but
neoconservatism is when a liberal is
mugged by reality and um and and that
happens to people we're seeing it now
with Hamas yeah have you seen that Meme
I don't not going to try and pull it
up it's uh I'll try and find it the the
the political persuasion you gain when
uh I don't know I I'll have to find it
uh at some point but it shows all the
different things that turns you into
various political ideologies so it's
like this graph and it shows you get you
you pay your April April 20th and it's
like become libertarian then it's like
gets mugged become
conservative you know gets a speeding
ticket becomes liberal is war on there
war starts become authoritarian no no no
like that's not on there I don't know
I'll try and find it but you guys think
that's natural and and actually a good
thing that we become more authoritarian
when we're our livelihoods are
threatened by War well I mean look um
I'm making this film as you guys know
police state and I had to think to
myself how did this come to America
because a police state is very alien to
America and then I realized
that
paradoxically this was a bipartisan
creation of the aftermath of 9/11
because a lot of Americans out of fear
were like listen we got these foreign
terrorists who knows when this is going
to happen again we need to stop the next
guy so we're going to give the
government all these new surveillance
Powers were're going to basically give
him a cart blanch do whatever he want
never thinking that 10 years later they
would take all that Armory of resources
and then turn it domestically and say
all right we now have a new Target
domestic extremists right uh and uh that
changes the whole game so that in my
view was the the sort of Genesis of the
American police state kind of like a
knee-jerk reaction almost to being under
attack without thinking about the
long-term uh possibil of that yeah well
when you're under when you're in fear
and you're in fear of attack you tend to
go to by any means necessary that's a
normal reaction I mean that that's what
you would think if Outlaw surrounded
your house I got I need to fight this by
any means necessary and and that's what
leads you to think I'm going to give the
government these powers that I wouldn't
normally give them this is why the left
love coid same thing they're like Co
creates a wartime environment in which
people are full of fear and when you're
full of fear you also trust experts
here's a man in a white lab coat take
this this pill will make you feel better
you're like oh okay no one's going to be
like well why are you giving me these
tests doctor what are these tests really
for and what does this pill really do
you defer to people who supposedly are
experts on all this and so this is a
wonderful way for the left to make
political
advances operating through the fear of
the American people do you think there
are environments where you can kind of
change your Society into a military
Society a militra without it turning on
itself
well the the Spartans did that for
centuries they had a very militaristic
culture and they would they would train
kid they essentially had Marshall acmy
as a substitute for schools and fighting
was their education and they were the
best at it and they developed all these
amazing techniques basically You' you'd
have a failan and everybody would hold a
shield you're not defending yourself
with your Shield your Shield defends the
guy to the right and you're defended by
The Shield of the guy to your left and
so the Spartans would move in the fail
lanks I mean they were so formidable
that in the pipian war the Greeks could
not fight them so the the the Athenians
decided when the war started we're going
to abandon all our land and go to Sea
because we can't fight the Spartans
oneon-one we'll let the Spartans come
and take all our land however eventually
the weakness of the failings was
discovered and they began flanking them
mhm well not only that but the Spartans
also didn't like technology apparently
someone came to the Spartan King aradus
and told him we've invented a way to
launch a projectile so we don't actually
have to fight manto man and the Spartan
King said I will give you a reward speak
to no one about this invention because
if this invention becomes widespread
basically military Valor will disappear
in Sparta wow so they were more
concerned with maintaining the military
virtue than having this kind of new
Gadget there there's some to that though
there with the uh Advent of um the
cartridge you ended up with conscription
I mean there was always some form of
conscription but but widespread military
conscription came to be when you didn't
need to train people yes anyone could
fight as soon as you had so obviously
with the musket you start seeing more
and more of it there's always some kind
of we have to go and fight to varying
degrees but then when you got U uh the
reloadable cartridge you end up with the
US going to all these countries and
being like not necessarily the us but
many uh weapons manufacturers and saying
now your farmers can fight hand them
this tell them to point and click all
they need to be trained is how to reload
and they're going to miss a whole lot
but it doesn't matter you don't need to
know technique anymore I watched that
movie I think it's the Last Samurai I
could be wrong Tom Cruz it might have
been The Last Samurai maybe not I don't
know I watched a movie where it was uh
uh I think that's what it was it's it's
in the 1800s and it's around when yeah
theend of the M yeah and so the samurai
who are trained and were these Elites
were no longer necessary and they were
losing political power yes right that's
crazy and soon it's going to be a dude
in a pod in an underground base with a
headset on flying a drone yeah we're
already basically but I mean like the
future of warfare is going to be silly
because going to be drones fighting
drones yeah it's so true you're going to
be in a factory and you're going to be
in a conflict Zone and then it's going
to be like the alarm's going to go off
and it's like flee all the humans are
going to evacuate and then it's going to
be a bunch of weird drones who crashing
into each other and robot dogs shooting
at each other and we'll see another
spart likee situation where the people
from the military industrial complex and
the governments are going to be like no
we want to use the weapons that we have
we really want to use our f7s we got to
use our long-range intercontinental
ballistic missiles and at the same time
you're getting ripped apart by drones or
some stupid new tech that's like well if
we use that then we're not going to be
able to use our toys it's like you you
got to adapt you're going to have to
adapt really rapidly to the new type of
War I mean look it was in the what was
the ' 80s Terminator the the concept of
an AI taking over our weapons before we
even had developed techn it's really
incredible it leads me to believe we're
probably going to build warp engines and
go travel the Galaxy because in the 80s
when computers were trash they were like
one day computers will be so strong and
so smart they'll take everything over
now we're looking at Ai and it's
terrifying I mean the the genius of that
movie Terminator one I think was the
best but two was pretty good too is that
it made a an accurate call in a way that
earlier science fiction never did you go
back and read HG Wells you know in the
early part of the 20th century and he
has the idea that you'd have these
massive lumbering robots like 20 feet
tall with big legs you know and they'd
be doing all this work for us but but
Terminator I think was a very
thought-provoking movie in its own way
and underestimated at the time but in in
retrospect I think it's like one of
these movies like sha Shank Redemption
over time it gets better we I I think
Terminator 2 was the big one like
Terminator was good they made a sequel
and Terminator 2 was just like was huge
huge Guns and Roses had a song in it um
obviously what Eddie uh need to be the
good guy Sarah Connor I mean it was the
it was a female uh hero the the whole
thing like the main character was this
badass woman it was awesome like alien
it was James James Cameron same director
as alien yeah so he's really good at
creating at that point he was what's
your fear with AI have you been studying
it have you done any documentaries on it
yet I haven't um no but it's um no I
think it's it changes the rules of the
game in so many ways I was telling Tim
earlier that I walk into my podcast you
know and um the the guy who's my does
the technical work on the podcast he's
took my last podcast and he put in some
Ai and there I am speaking fluent
Spanish
and uh my mouth is moving and I'm and my
wife who venezuel and she's like oh my
she was like stunned you know speechless
for a moment because so think about
think about the the POS just from that
simple idea the possibilities of
manipulation I mean I can see the
promise of it but I can also see the
Peril of it here's here's the start
within a within a couple years YouTube
rolls out the autot translate button oh
yeah that will just press a button and
then all everyone's speaking Spanish or
German or Japanese and then from there
you have the techn to just create a
podcast you could literally just we're
we're we're almost to the point where
you can type in to one of these AIS give
me an episode of timcast IRL with Alex
Jones Joe Rogan and Donald Trump and it
will AI generate the whole thing and it
will seem
real I mean think about that Tim and I
could be huge in Japan that's right but
I will say very quickly as of today
today probably not because uh uh Sheamus
cogin Freedom Tunes he put out this
hilarious video called asking g chat GPT
to make a freedom tunes cartoon and uh
he basically asks chat GPT to write a
script for a freedom tunes cartoon based
on ones he's already done and one of
them is Ben Ben chapiro having
Thanksgiving with his family and it's
actually really funny and he's like
surprised there's like uh uh one of the
kids goes can I grow up to be when I
grow up can I be a conservative it's
like funny things like that but then he
types in Bernie Sanders having
Thanksgiving with his family and it made
the exact same script but changed Ben
for Bernie so it's like not quite there
yet but it actually still was kind of
funny but we're getting there we're
getting there I was picturing um I
mentioned Napoleon earlier and how he
one of his greatest achievements was the
ability to decentralize command among
his his Marshals and create a core
system that a a military a Victorious
military uh government is going to do
that with drone with artificial
intelligence and decentralize its
command amongst a bunch of different
artificial intelligences because it's
going to be so effective they're going
to win but it's so risky that one of the
AI is going to go Rogue and take over
and then it's going to become man on
machine I'm afraid of that what what
what did you say about Napoleon he was
good at decentralizing Command right but
so so I just wanted to add I wouldn't
bring up Napoleon as it pertains to uh
developing new technologies in military
because of this quote you would make a
ship sail against the winds and currents
by lighting a bonfire under her decks I
have no time for such nonsense that's a
great quote that was Napoleon that's
like the classic it's like the classic
exactly with the the Spartans were
saying or something we don't want this
new tech to come and disrupt what we
already have going for us cuz he's from
the age of sale he didn't agree with the
idea of having a ship with a motor like
oh that's that's so non manly you hear
that all the time and then that
ultimately becomes the way of the world
I went down I watched a documentary on
the ironclads yeah and then uh because
we're we we we drove down to a national
park where we actually uh got to see
like a bunch of the rivers and stuff and
look at the stories and then I went we
went to a an aquarium that actually
there's like a a crashed Ironclad yeah
dude when people realized we can coat
the top of our boat with metal and then
put an engine underneath a steam engine
we can we we we own and there's crazy
stories where like the Confederates had
this Ironclad and they're firing on a
union ship and then they I someone's
going to know the story better than me
because I'm not a historian anything but
one of the guys on the union ship runs
over and he's like he pulls the cord or
whatever to fire it hits the Ironclad
bounces right off and then lands back on
a ship blowing him up and killing oh man
that's wild yeah crazy stuff and then
there but but it's also like they
eventually figured out that the the
Smoke Stacks or whatever on the
ironclads were the weak point and if you
got rid of it the air flow couldn't come
in and keep the fire going and it would
shut them down dude War like was that
the was that the
monitor I don't remember War technology
history is is amazing the history of War
technology and how technology is often
the key factor in how a civilization
decays the if you've been to Venice the
um you know they have Carnival and how'
they get Carnival well the venetians
actually were the dominant shipping
power in the
Mediterranean but the Spanish set to
work on building a better ship the
caravel basically the ships that
Columbus got yeah and the venetians knew
about it but they didn't go that way
they decided we're not going to go there
we don't need it we we dominate the
region so the Spanish built a better
ship and they crossed the ocean and got
to the Americas they changed the whole
balance of power not just toward Europe
but inside of Europe and then Venice
could never recover from that so they
said
basically let's party and that's the
origin and they've been doing it for 300
years so the Spanish prioritized
exploration over destructive capability
and that ended up making them more
powerful yes well the Spanish uh and it
wasn't just the love of exploration I
mean the Spanish wanted to find a better
way to get to India to the spice uh
Riches of India and and also gold so a
combination of religious devotion uh
commercial enthusiasm and and also just
love of exploration all those things
came together in Columbus here's what I
love I went we went to a restaurant
we're in Miami you know me Luke my
girlfriend we're hanging out and uh we
order the food and of course you have
the very nice server walk over and say
fresh pepper for your soup sir and he
crushes the little black pepper thing on
your on on your soup or your salad
literally whatever it is you're eating
they ask if you want black pepper why
this used to be like the most valuable
thing in the world I I it probably how
many how many people died in wars
because of black pepper and now it just
sits on every Diner you go to a waffle
house and of course they've got you go
you you like you have little packages
with with with black pepper in it in
fact people just throw it away no one
cares anymore I mean and not just pepper
salt I mean for for 300 years in the
Middle Ages even rich people would eat
meat but they didn't have salt yeah in
the Bible I think it was in the the the
New Testament they talk they mentioned
that salt has flavor there's a flavor
salt has a flavor to it I don't i' never
think of that these days cuz it's
everywhere I just it's I'm so
desensitized to the of kinds of salt too
I worked at this place place called Salo
Italo once which just based off of like
different kinds of salts on food didn't
last very long we have lava salt yeah
it's because we bought the wagyu we had
one time and so you get the lava salt
you put on the wagyu beef and it's got
carbon in it I guess so it turns black
so we conquered well we I say this this
Imperial conquest of Earth basically to
to compile all the foods or for one of
the one of the war score goals or one of
the victories that we got was uh all
this food but like now I'm concerned
about CL Schwab saying you're going to
be eating bugs in a pod if they really
want to control and unify the world
what's the what's the incentive like
you're going to have to make things
better if you want to control Earth not
not worse so I don't well not
necessarily because I think one of the
things that struck me I was really
surprised by is as I was working on you
know police state police state in
America I thought to myself wait a
minute a lot of the coid restrictions
for example that we saw in America we
see them in Canada we saw them in Europe
we see them in Australia uh a lot of of
the issues of election fraud that we are
debating in America we see in Brazil so
suddenly we realize that our our our
danger isn't just a police state but a
police Planet because there's the risk a
prison planet yeah a prison planet in
which the entire population of the world
is under the control of some uh
decentralized Elite but it's an elite in
communication with each other I mean the
Marvel of today is that you have
collaboration without conspiracy I mean
here a crazy example of that the
suppression of the hunter Biden story
this is a real puzzle now I can
understand if you're running Stalin's
regime it's easy to suppress the hunter
Biden story nobody gets to publish it or
they get killed or even under you know
Geral he's the propaganda minister of
Germany he just instructs all the media
you can't do it everything is under the
control of the state but in America we
have hundreds of news organizations
thousands of journalists and normal
libertarian Theory would tell you okay
if people don't want to publish the to
Biden story some guy at the Sacramento B
or the Denver Post or the Dallas Morning
News is going to be like you idiots can
be my guest and not publish the story
I'm going to publish the story I'm going
to have the biggest story and but the
fact that no one did it think about it
think about the level of regimentation
there has to be where the ordinary
reporter who's not that political goes I
cannot touch that story because if I do
the Sword of Damocles will fall on my
head and chop my head off and I can't do
it not one guy did it post didn't the
New York Post reported on it right so
when the New York Post being the only
one to go out forward suddenly it was
almost like there was a
massive media mobilization to shut those
people down to take them off the
internet to shut down the story and the
media was applauding have you found that
um of these news organizations are are
working in secret behind the scenes like
a lot of them do you have any evidence
have you no I I think this is I think
what makes it even more scary I mean
it's you know if we could find evidence
that they all got on a 6 a.m. Zoom call
and they all said let's not do it I
would at least go oh okay that's how
that happened I find it even scarier to
find that human beings are motiv operate
like birds flying to Florida in the
Summer where they're not communicating
they're not on a zoom call but they take
signals from each other and they're all
able to maintain a flying formation
right it's like Taca it's like a lot I
was reminded of George Carlin saying
there doesn't need to be a formal
conspiracy for people to act with the
same interest or the same underlying
interest towards doing something and
that's exactly what you're talking about
it was just tacit people just did it
because they were just like well I'm too
scared to fall out of the flock I'm too
scared to be attacked by my neighbor
because of what I say and do and that
was really scary that was creepy that
whole the whole laptop story now it's
been totally it's been totally ratified
and it's just reality people accept it
as it's like jokes you hear jokes about
it now like every day it's wild I think
I think they're losing control yeah I
agree I think the internet caught the
powers that be by surprise they can't
control it anymore they're desperately
trying but they just they've lost the
grip
for a little bit there it it appeared
that when they had when they had Twitter
and YouTube and Google and Facebook and
and those guys were working in
coordination I mean interestingly like
Alex Jones was banned on those platforms
within five minutes of each other so
think about that they had to be in
communication they had to to to to make
a deal that way I I think that for this
reason what Elon Musk has done is very
significant and I think has historic
significance when we look back the oh
yeah it's ride open the uh the the the
closing um can of free speech and with
the development of Mesh networking and
things like that and where our networks
can go phone device to device without
some sort of central Authority it seems
like we're headed in a path towards
bypassing Central Authority this is a
cool thing yeah when I was on a uh I
mean anybody who's gone on a cruise
probably has noticed this already
depending on the cruise but I went out
to uh there was a cruise called Summit
AT C and this is built as like a bunch
of influential people I'll buy a cruise
ticket and then everyone interacts but
when when you go they told everyone
download this app it creates a mesh
Network through Bluetooth so that
everyone can chat with each other as if
there was a cell tower nearby it's the
craziest thing so basically what happens
is you're on one side of the ship you
send a message to your friend John that
message SE your phone connects to any
nearby Bluetooth in the network and then
it Ricochet off every device until it
finds his and then he gets the message
it's pretty cool without everyone else
like seeing it too no no yeah no because
they're it's encrypted right and so it
only seeks out the the phone the
decryption key from the person who has
it I think in the future your your
computer you'll be able to click a
little switch in the bottom right where
it'll say like activate mesh and then
you your computer will just be part of
the network the mesh Network anyone else
that wants to mesh into it GPS is is
mostly becoming uh uh irrelevant I mean
not really but kind of a lot of people
uh maybe don't know this your phone
tracks your location through ambient
signals not necessarily through
satellites anymore off cell towers yeah
right when you're using um and here's
the crazy thing Google Maps on Android
right now is not even using that it's
using pictures yeah so if you have low
accuracy and it doesn't know where you
are it says Point your camera out the
window and then it uses Google Earth
data what so by you filming the trees as
you drive down the highway it'll be like
found you yeah when I learned that it
like blew my mind it was terrifying
actually Des do you are you concerned
about the metaverse or not not
necessarily Mark Zuckerberg's but just
the concept of going into a neuronet
universe and kind of living your daily
life in this thing or do you think it's
a good a benefit for the species how how
do you view it well I think that
um the problem I think is is bigger than
that the metaverse is like the latest
chapter of this and that is that we have
Visual and virtual reality and I I admit
as a filmmaker I you know I create the
same that if you don't it has the risk
of pulling us away from real human
feelings and so our feelings are become
increasingly simulated they're not even
really real uh and and by that I mean
we're accustomed to a certain type let's
take for example a politician who sees
some of these horrific images right he
goes oh my god there are children who
are being held hostage and are being
slaughtered and you feel that emotion as
if it was your own kid but like for 3
seconds right because then somebody goes
hey I got a hamburger here you know you
want cheese you know and so we're now in
this world where we have the extreme
reaction but it's then we go right back
to a mundane reality and so the
metaverse just takes this concept to a
whole new level where you can have a
surrogate identity you can you can meet
a have a virtual girlfriend you know you
can buy real estate in the meterse and
you're you know so suddenly you have a
surrogate life this is why people don't
don't get there's two reasons why you
will live in the Pod and you'll be happy
you'll live in the Pod you'll eat the
bugs and you'll be happy the first
reason is when they take away your
children's knowledge of what could be
they won't want it so 100 years ago
let's say let's say 200 years ago nobody
was complaining about not having air
conditioning there wasn't air
conditioning you just go and cool off by
the water and hole or fan yourself now
that we have air conditioning people are
like why don't you have air conditioning
oh I there's restaurants people won't go
no you don't have air conditioning now
we have to have it they take away your
knowledge of what could be and you will
be like wow the pot is fun but the other
reason is because it's not living in a
pot
you going to be a king you're going to
come home from work if you're even going
to work and some people will still have
real reality based jobs but most people
will work in like uh White Collar jobs
in the Pod your house will be a box
you'll go inside and lock the door lay
back and then your eyes will roll back
in your head or whatever and then you're
instantly in a gigantic Mansion where
your e dog runs up to you and your dog
Never Dies your cat Never Dies we took a
scan of your old cat from when you were
a kid made a fake version of it your a
AI wife walks up to you she'll never
leave you she's everything you ever
wanted her to be we were talking about
that at the event last Friday um ever
crack I was talking with the guys from
pbd podcast yeah and EverQuest the video
game and he was like when the power
would go out like no I lost my life like
my whole my my person I'm gone and we
were talking about the Met like getting
into the metaverse and the danger of
like if you have a surrogate love if you
really in love and that gets turned off
like what in the hell you're complete
slave to that system at that point two
of the great dystopian works of the 20th
century were huxley's Brave New World
which is actually this what you're just
describing and the other of course is
Orwell and interestingly it's you know
if at that time I thought we may go this
way or we may go that way but it never
occurred to me that we would actually go
both ways so we're now getting a hybrid
of Huxley and Orwell so Orwell says that
a police state is a boot stamping on a
human face right and we have some of
that and in the this is what I do in the
film I mean we I want the ordinary
citizen to see that because Americans
have a great difficulty getting their
heads around the fact that that could
happen here but the Huxley part of it is
another way a police state lulls a
citizen into sort of complacency it's
like we'll give you manufactured
experience now manufactured experience
is not real experience in the sense that
it it's it's not the real thing right I
mean living your life with a real woman
and and going through all that has a
texture and complex it that an e
girlfriend or even a porn video cannot
Supply but Tim's point is what if you
don't know that what if you think that
this porn experience is actually sexual
experience this is romantic experience
I've got a girlfriend why would I want a
real one uh this one never complains
this is what's going on you're
forgetting one name as well it's not
just Orwell or Huxley it's also Bradbury
Fahrenheit 451 it's all coming together
what's that story Fahrenheit 451 people
became so offended that the society
built up an firemen who would go and
Destroy offensive materials right and
and it's not about the government doing
it it's about the people collectively
being like if you make a book critical
of of the unions well that's offensive
to unions you can't have that if someone
likes dogs what's offensive to cat owner
so you got to get rid of it all and so
what's what's H what's going to happen
is you're going to have the police
demanding hey it's past curfew get in
your pod then you're going to have that
but don't worry in your pod you're
eating nothing but cheesecake you're
eating you're eating creme cookie dough
caramel fudge cheesecake triple dipped
deep fried every minute of every waking
hour whatever you could want pulsing
your ass stronger and it's safer cuz
we're always at War have to be and but
but then there's all the information
removed from your existence because
everyone's shocked and offended by it so
in your private reality you have
whatever you want but no one dare go
outside of it or interact there's going
to be the solo player pod your own
private Universe sometimes you can
invite friends in but it's just for you
and then there's going to be the
interactive PVP version but no one dare
do anything exciting there because too
offensive right I mean think of the
irony right now on campus you've got
people who for a decade have been
talking about being triggered and
needing a safe space and
microaggressions and you offended me by
not using my pronouns and those same
people are like
Hamas know what I mean they're cheering
real
murder and yet these rhetorical offenses
were EV evidently so intolerable and
unbearable to them and morally offensive
and those same people when confronted
with real atrocities are like hm we're
okay with that one yeah I don't imagine
that the Hamas government would use
their
pronouns well it's also like I was
thinking about that when we were
watching that video where they were
chanting basically you know Hitler's
thing and I'm like they were literally
fighting against Fascism and now they're
on for Hitler's fascism yeah it was
crazy how fast they were able to adopt a
Nazi phrase and a phrase all this why
this is why I say it's like an inversion
that's why I say the left has no moral
framework it's a chaotic and destructive
force it makes no sense they're like
those words are offensive and then they
go and cheer for heras it's it's it's
it's like Bizarro world it's an
inversion we here as moral people are
like innocent people shouldn't die but
offensive words may be necessary because
sometimes offensive ideas are the right
ideas and sometimes inoffensive ideas
are the wrong ideas the left is inverted
no no one should be allowed to speak but
what Hamas did it's it's it's it's a
it's like czy it's it's an inverted
world of nonsense morality it's crazy
yeah they're they're falling into the
oppressor oppressed category I mean a
lot of it comes from the establishment
of the Jewish State over the course of
the 19th century but but it's not it's
when when they say like or 18th 20th
century if if a homeless white person a
homeless a homeless veteran a white man
on the ground they say he's the oppress
oppressor and Oprah Winfrey is the
oppressed I'm not kidding that's their
argument based on race a white veteran
homeless man has more power than opra
does that is nonsensical yep uh removal
of that is The Logical extension of
systematic racism right and in fact it's
the nonsensical logic or illogic of
intersectionality right so
intersectionality is that this was
actually a very clever device thought of
by a law professor a black law professor
in the Midwest and she was she's a black
woman and she's like listen you know I
don't want all the Civil Rights Prestige
to go to Martin Luther King and all
these black guys how do how do we get
the black women ahead of them right and
the answer is double oppression so the
black guy is a victim of racism so he's
got like one point but I'm a victim of
racism and sexism two points and of
course if I'm a black female lesbian or
or have one leg then I've got three
points so it becomes like like a
inverted totem pole but this this this
was actually not even hypothetical
you're quite literally describing the
algorithmic machine that was built on
social media so Facebook launches their
algorithm for the first time and we see
a wave of police brutality videos
because people don't like Injustice and
so they're like wow I can't believe this
happening of all people police shouldn't
be doing this right they're supposed to
protect us what happened is many of
these websites were started making
insane amounts of money when they kept
posting this this rage bait of police
brutality but then something happened
someone posted racist police brutality
all of a sudden they're getting 2x the
views so that police brutality plus
racism is not just one point two points
it's it's not X Plus y it's XY it's
multiplied what ended up happening is
you get some of the most absurd articles
imaginable where it's like Vice writes
black Trans women uh black Trans
lesbians personify black lives matter
and uh denounce police brutality from
white supremacist they Jam all of these
words into the headline so the algorithm
will promote it more oh yeah it's going
to different groups so the idea of
intersectionality actually emerges
mechanically through our social media
platforms because that's what the the
machine would share the most if if
someone clicks on racism the algorithm
says people like this show them more if
someone clicks on sexism they like this
show them more but you put them both
together everyone's clicking on it now
so intersectionality fit the mold
perfectly for promotion algorithm very
interesting it's it's technology meets
ideology and um so the ideology came
first CU these ideas go back to the late
1980s but of course at that time they
were not powered by this sort of there
were no algorithms to drive them uh and
then the algorithms well I mean there's
the algorithms were programmed in this
way because it's obviously you know
inputs and outputs what's right now
we're watching human identity fracture
and shatter into a million pieces to the
point where for the past 10 years you've
had the emergence of otherkin you are
you familiar with otherkin I've heard
the term but I don't even know what it
means trans mythical species there are
people who identify as elf Dragon Lords
and stuff like this and it's like you
might assume it's nonsensical and it and
it's not as in the realm of reality but
a lot of people do say like I'm an
owlkin like I have an owl spirit in me
and things like this they I'm actually
identify as a wolf as we watch reality
break down human beings you know like
someone who is male is identifying as
female people identifying as animals
there was one very prominent individual
who was male but identified as a female
tiger and got surgery to look like a
tiger oh I saw that well that person
took their own life what M as we're
watching the chaos rise and identity
fracture if we move into a metaverse
reality give it a couple generations and
you will it will what you will see
inside of people's pods we make the joke
I I made the joke that you're going to
live in the Pod and you're going to be
in a mansion with a woman no no no no no
so in a couple generations of this
continued fracturing of identity you
will you will take a look the government
will say let's go spy on you know this
person's pod experience and they're
going to click it and they're going to
be a piece of cake vibrating on a
bowling ball that's spinning around
around a moon with a bunch of carrots
twirling in the air and you're like
it'll be like code the hell are they
even it's not even that it's going to be
nonsensical abstractions of complete
fractured identity and the cake person
has been
going that's what I meant by sorry
interrupting it's just going to be it's
going to be expanding complexity of
nonsense it's the end of human nature
isn't it there's a there's an important
book from uh the last century by the
Harvard biologist eio Wilson it's called
onum nature and he talks about human
nature has certain parameters now
there's there's a variation within those
parameters but he says try to imagine a
human being that decided I'm going to be
a toad right he goes but I mean not just
I identify like a toad like I want to
look like a toad I wear a toad costume
or something but I want to be a toad I
am a toad in fact I'm a toad in a human
body I'm really a toad but I'm in the
wrong body he goes you would have to go
down to the creek and jump around in the
water and eat what toads eat and be a
toad right now imagine if someone
actually did that now I think most of us
at least the libertarian streak in us
would be that's interesting let's go
check that dude out you know and but it
would be a whole different matter if
that guy then began to demand that the
whole of society recognize him as a toad
right and and so this effort to not only
say my mind has given me this new
identity but I'm now insisting that
you subscribe to this idti you buy into
my illusion so to speak yes this is
where I think we go off the rail but
where are we going if we do go into this
metaverse we had that Lex fridman Mark
Zuckerberg interview you guys see it I
think you pointed out saw it where their
their animated CGI figures it looks just
like them and they're talking from
across the country but they're in the
same room sitting down and you can see
their bodies and face moving as if
they're not you know it's it's real-time
generation here's what's going to happen
you you think it's absurd to recognize
the toad person when the whole world is
in the metaverse there is going you're
going to walk into your business you're
going to put on your headset and you're
going to grab your controllers haptic
feedback or whatever your avatar will be
you regular old dases walking you'll sit
down at this table and like all right
everybody ready for the production
meeting and there will be a giant toad
and there will be a giant carrot person
and then there will be a Godzilla and
that's how they identify and so the Frog
man will be like I would like to discuss
and you're like that's just that's what
we do now the in the in the reality in
which we operate people are whatever
they want to be I've been continuing to
remind people that if you're a human man
and you identify whatever is a woman is
a brick wall you're both a woman and a
human man you never stop becoming one
you're still a human man that identifies
you don't become anything else well you
identify as something else but you never
truly stop being a human man that's part
of your experience a human man who
identifies as a carrot is still a human
man who identifies as a carrot yeah
exactly and you can be both there's an
imprecision here because the person
who's saying that wants you to believe
even though they use the sly word
identify what they really mean
is I am a woman in the wrong body
they're not saying I am imagining myself
to be a woman I'm a man who imagines
myself to be a woman what they're saying
is I really am a woman but I am in a
sense in I've given been I've been
ascribed the wrong biology and that's
why I have to undertake all these
surgeries and hormones and all this
stuff this matters now but when we are
in a digital reality there will be no
question because you'll meet some you
you you'll be talking to as far as you
can tell in virtual reality a woman and
you'll have no idea that it's a
middle-aged morbidly obese man behind
the
screen it's in the movie surrogates uh
with Bruce Willis this is the first
thing they introduce it's like there's
some hot woman and some dude at a club
making out the movie is about people who
use robots to Pilot the world for them
because it's safer and then when they go
when this when the when the person dies
the the the surrogate of the female dies
they're like let's go track down the
owner and see what happened they walk
into this very beautiful apartment and
this a 500 lb man in the machine who's
dead and they're like that's her yep
that's great yep you get that a little
bit in in uh role playing games like
World of Warcraft and stuff where a dude
chooses to play as a as a female half
elf or a female night elf and I'm like
well but I don't I don't see that I
don't see that as as the same way it's a
question of when you when when you play
with dolls are you controlling the doll
or are you becoming the doll and
everybody kind of does it differently
right I do yeah I don't I don't become I
mean I I guess you could you could
pretend to be you're making the
characters you're like hello I'm this
guy yeah I'm this guy if you if you're
if you're playing in World of Warcraft
and your role playing and you're like I
would like to be a a
half people would get married reality
what's that you acknowledge it's a game
and not reality cuz you're playing a a
game right people get married in the
game and do you identify as your
character or is your character a thing
you manipulate yeah but it was you're
right because it was some people were
that was just a manipulative character
some people they started to identify
I think and then maybe it's
psychoactives maybe it's like Pharma
drugs that are making people at 12 years
old not know reality from fiction no I I
I mean it it depends some people go into
these games specifically to roleplay as
a character that either is or is not
themsel but when I played World of
Warcraft I had like seven different we
called them tunes and some were male and
some were female it was just like action
figures yeah but and then if someone
asks you like are you a girl and you're
like yes that's when it goes a little
crazy but we were on what was it team
speak and what was the other one was it
vector or whatever um lot of was it
things like vector chat yeah everybody
knows who we are we're hanging out
together and it's like we're I I it's
like playing with action figures it's
almost as if what's happening in our
society is that at one level we're
seeing
increased clampdown regimentation
control uh governments Elites and and
it's not just governments I mean our
police state is a little bit unique in
that it sprawls across the private
sector too I mean think of censorship
censorship involves academ
it involves the media it involves
nonprofit institutions it involves the
government and the digital platforms so
an academic will make up a list right
and let's just say Tim pool and I on the
list got to ban these two guys that list
will then be picked up by the Biden
Administration which will then sort it
oh Timol is spreading lies about the
election send it over to cisa the cyber
security and infrastructure Aid dases is
spreading lies about coid send them over
to the CDC so all these agencies compile
these lists but then they don't want to
explicitly censor cuz they might get
caught so they hand it off to a
middleman they go to the Stanford
internet Observatory the virality
project they go guys you take this list
and you deliver it to the digital
platforms so that way we're out of it
you and so that they do the handoff the
digital platforms ban you and the media
cheers and they don't make any specific
statements of fact that way they can't
be sued so I actually dealt with this
they I think Stanford claimed that I was
one of the largest uh uh me and people
were the biggest promoters of of
disinformation in the in the during the
2020 election which is the weirdest
thing to say I did because I have like
the most tepid opinions on these things
and we use newsguard which is Microsoft
funded not like they have they have a
contract deal so they're getting a lot
of financing through a deal with
Microsoft I put out a story where I'm
like hey look local Fox Outlet says X
and they're like Tim pool spreads
thisinformation you ask them where or
how they don't have to tell you and they
don't have to argue what is or isn't and
you can't zoom over it I mean to me the
most creepy word that came out of the
Twitter files was Mal information so Mal
information is information that's true
yeah but harmful to the ideology of the
regime kind of something like you can
take the vaccine and you can still get
coid and you can still give Co yeah well
people go wait a minute that how is it a
quote vaccine vaccines by definition
prevent you from getting it and prevent
you and so that becomes Malin it's not
wrong it's actually true that's why they
want to B at first it was I think it was
misinformation and they were like some
people are spreading information
accidentally incorrect then it became
disinformation like now they're
intentionally doing it then Mal
information it may be true but it is bad
for a lot of reasons that I mean again
flashing back you know a generation
disinformation used to mean information
that is deliberately false that is put
out by a government Soviet
disinformation coming out through Pravda
is vestia all these Soviet propag but
the idea that an ordinary individual
debating a vaccine could be doing
disinformation is absurd you can be
misinformed you could be even malicious
you could be lying but disinformation
again that term was ripped out of its
original context and used in a
completely different context I mean I I
would assume um that a that a citizen
could provide disinformation as if they
were a Soviet government like one one
brilliant guy that has access to a lot
of data could could definitely with a
lot of followers could seed like a false
narrative but the argument was that in a
free Marketplace of ideas your peers
could check you they could challenge you
so the idea that you could monopolize
disinformation it wouldn't really work
whereas on the other hand if a
government was doing it then they could
sort of control the flow of it here's
the challenge let's say the government
releases an AI image and then the people
check that image and says hey wait a
minute this is AI generated then news
organizations through statements made by
the government confirm actually it's
real and people just what do you do
you've got multiple news organizations
and a government saying actually we
checked it's real and users being like
we ran algorithms and said it's fake
people are going to be it's it's just
nonsense world there's nothing that's
true anymore that's where that's where
we're entering we're in this we're we're
here now to some degree think about how
often we are told who do you believe us
or Your Lying Eyes you know so take
January 6th most of us had a pretty good
view of what happened there was a lot of
coverage of the event you could see yeah
there was some episodic violence there
were some clashes some of it got pretty
bad there were people who climbed
through windows and up up the banisters
and so on at other stages you have
people wandering very carefully through
the ropes making sure not to deface or
damage anything and so all of this was
right there in front of you to see but
then a whole manufactured narrative came
up which was quite different from what
we saw and the January 6 committee is
believe this don't believe what you saw
yep I think of that with 911 too when I
watch those buildings fall and near Free
Fall speed just like well you take a
look at Jan 6 being a good example we
did on this show I think this was almost
two years ago now I talked about how on
January 6 we would likely end up with
with January 6 we would likely end up
seeing aquid because you can't charge
someone with trespass unless they've
been warned they're trespassing and so
the problem with January 6 is that many
people arrived later on in the day when
the fences were removed the doors were
opened by the police and they walked in
confused The Young Turks particularly
Jen yuger made a made a clip insulting
me saying that's the stupidest argument
ever Tim pool's as if these people
are fighting with police and walking
over broken glass and don't know they're
trespassing you see the problem was that
jenin Anna did not actually know what
happened on January 6th they had only
seen what CNN wanted them to see and
they didn't know on the other side of
the building cops opened the door and
fanned people in well sure enough a
couple months later there was a hard
acqu one man argued to the judge the
police fanned me in the defense plays a
video of the cops going like this and
waving them in and the judge said you
are correct sir you are free to go case
dismissed and that's not the only one
another man got acquitted on the uh uh
on the trespass charge because the
police no he got he got acquitted on a
bunch of charges in including the
trespass without warning but then he got
a lighter charge because he climbed over
a barricade later on or something to
that effect there was like a half
acquittal some of the charges got
dropped because the police are seen
Fanning him in but then later on he
climbed past a barricade or something
but we've seen several people get
acquitted because the cops fan him in if
The Young Turks don't know this then of
course they're going to say how could
Tim say something like this the problem
is an inquisitive mind would say wait
wait wait what is Tim Paul talking about
right people didn't know how is that
possible let let me search for this whoa
I didn't realize the cops fanned people
in this is one of the biggest challenges
we face right now in the culture war is
ignorant anger but it's even more than
that now it's ignorant like I haven't
seen all the videos coming out of Gaza
or Israel I haven't so I'm ignorant I
don't know what's going on but then I
see videos that aren't real so I start
to think that I have seen what's going
on but it what didn't actually happen
that's even it's like is that that's
kind of even worse than not
knowing yeah part of it is we have also
been you know in in a sphere of vast
knowledge none of us can be in a
position to know across the board right
and therefore in in in a society you
trust institutions and authorities that
have expertise in a particular area
classic example being the medical
establishment does this drug work do I
have these sys and what does it mean how
long do I have to live doctor you know
and so you defer to these authorities
and and we have been doing it but
suddenly a lot of these institutions the
FBI the
CDC we've realized have are not above
lying to us bald-faced and and also not
above the most nefarious motives like
you know here's fouchy and he he goes oh
shoot this virus might have come out of
the Wuhan lab guess what I've been
funding this gain of function research
in North Carolina those guys are working
with the Wuhan lab this could be I could
be like Mangal I mean I could be blamed
for millions of people dying I got to
make sure that people think this virus
came out of a wet Market uh nearby so
then he calls up some researchers these
are basically people on the government
payroll but they're are world-class
researchers and he says you guys I know
you got some doubts but whip out a paper
saying that the virus came out of a wet
market and these guys like oh yeah my
Grant's coming up for Renewal happy to
do so Mr fouchy they show him the paper
beforehand he knows all about it but
then he goes to a press conference and
he asks this is a mea Oscar winning
performance he goes you know I've just
come across this important paper by
these worldclass virologists saying that
the virus came from a wet market so
fouchy you know so what I'm getting at
here is that police States when they are
under construction when you're building
them you need a lot of subt Refuge you
need a lot of flimflam you need a lot of
smoke and mirrors you need a lot of
lying now when you got a full-fledged
police state you don't need any lying
you just walk into a train station grab
a guy you don't give him any reasons you
beat him over the head he'll never be
seen from again but while you're
building the police state you need to
fool people and so you that's that's
what's going on and so we I think that
our distrust of these institutions is
completely Justified I I wonder if we're
seeing a shift and I I uh someone super
chatted that uh you know even Dave poroy
was supporting Nikki Haley and so I I
just looked and I see Dave pornoy
supporting Nikki Haley yeah and the
statement was Nikki Haley saying
something like um when Israel moves into
GA invades Gaza people are going to call
for restraint but Hamas showed no
restraint when they invaded Israel and
Dave's like I like Nikki more and more
I'm wondering if what might happen and
this there's a lot of bad things to this
but a lot of good just hear me out it
will be very bad if we get a fervent
zealous War Machine emerging from what
we're seeing but the potential good is
that that the anti-war faction people
like with a more libertarian streak
become what the left used to be or what
the right so what happens is the modern
version of the identity left ceases to
exist because of their overt support for
Terror and then what's left is the
dominant factions in the culture War
become like moderate libertarian leaning
Freedom folks anti-establishment being
like hey we don't want war but we agree
Hamas is bad no identity politics versus
no identity politics you're right about
that but we want to defend Israel and we
want for an intervention and so it
reverts back to the old school left and
right of anti-war versus I'm concerned
that it would be an identitarian
authoritarian uh no I'm saying that's
that's that's that's dying out the
identi saying we might be able to to
root those guys out and replace them
with a new two-party system in which you
have sort of a proar authoritarian party
and a more libertarian anti-war party I
wouldn't say authoritarian I think pro-
intervention versus anti- intervention
yeah I mean I think this is the you know
we were talking earlier about about
Trump and I think part of the Ingenuity
of trump is that he he was essentially I
don't want to get our country into a war
but I'm not against administering a
well-deserved ass kicking from time to
time yeah and I think that's where most
Americans are you know Americans are
like look I'm we're not looking for a
big ground war here but on the other
hand there are really bad guys in the
world and we have to figure out ways to
teach them a lesson no amount of
cocktail parties and quote negotiations
and you know giving them giving them
money and pallets is going to really do
the the the job you have to hold them
accountable I disagree I mean uh uh it
wasn't so much an ass kicking it was the
threat of one by a crazy guy and uh you
know the thing about um about Donald
Trump is that he he's he's got 20
Charisma so when he shows up and he
negotiates it actually starts getting
things done you've got uh uh the Abraham
Accords despite the fact you know Max
blo thought said he thought they were
bad and they set up the situation we
have now I'm not so sure I agree but you
know I he's a lot of his opinion he's
done a lot of research on on the area
though he has his biases but uh what Max
did agree with me on he made a very
funny joke but I'll Reserve that for his
right to say I don't I wouldn't steal it
from him but he said that he was very
much impressed and grateful when he saw
Trump negotiate with Kim Jong-un and
cross the DMZ I said the same thing I
said when I saw Donald Trump cross the
the demilitarized zone into North Korea
with no security detail I was I was near
tears the American
president the left will not accept this
that the Liberals will not accept this
Donald Trump risked his life entering an
enemy country with their dictator
because he wanted peace could you
imagine what North Korea could have done
North Korea famously will snatch South
Korean soldiers and pull them in MH
Donald Trump willfully crossed over and
there's the famous photo in the video he
goes up there he shakes shakes hands
they wave he walks back a tremendous
effort towards peace amazing amazing
Donald Trump was doing and I bet you
that with a conventional State
Department bureaucracy they all begged
him not to do it yep they probably told
him do not do that what the media say
they said he's becoming friends with
evil men and dictators and it's just
like should we just go to war and drop
bombs well the military-industrial
complex would love that now I don't know
about Blumenthal but with regard to the
Abraham Accords in a weird way you could
say that they set up the current
conflict but but not in the way I think
that is normally meant they set up the
current conflict in that they produced a
fear in Hamas that Israel is now cutting
deals that's what Max said right oh yeah
okay and so what happens is Hamas
because we can't allow this to happen so
what we need to do is we need to do
something really bad which will then
cause Israel to do something in
retaliation that will then inflame the
entire Muslim world and will crash down
the abrahamic Accords so this is not a
critique of trump in fact it is
essentially saying kind of what the left
thinks we have to undo everything that
Trump did and in a weird way they're
trying to Hamas is trying to do that
also we're going to go to super chats so
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and head over to
timcast.net company and uh it's like
it's optional you know it's like the
main show it's always free for you guys
but then we have the special members
only stuff so if you want to watch the
uncensored members only show and be a
caller call in and talk to us you can
also join and become a member those are
Monday through Thursday but we're going
to read your super chats now Clint
Torres wins the first Super Chat
impressively at the 740 Mark wow so we
click that's CR stream at 740 which
gives a 20- minute buffer for the the
link to exist and Clint you've you've
you've you've got the record nailed it
he says howdy people Ian happy to hear
about your spiritual journey might I
recommend Bible in a year podcast Tim
the podcast host father Mike schmidtz
would be an awesome guest for y'all's
religious debate thank you Bible in your
podast I don't think we're doing a
religious debate I think it's Sheamus
it's fresh it's Ian and it's going to be
a conversation around religious ideas I
think we really really fascinating I've
been doing going live on Twitter I'm
probably not going to be on later
tonight but uh it's been really great I
was on for five hours last night we had
like 2,000 people came through and 20
speakers or something it was great we
also I will say uh the music setup for
Friday night music is is here and we're
we're getting ready for that to exist
which means we're gonna actually have
musical guests and then Friday nights
it's not just like you know back in the
early days uh we'd play music we would
just Jam a couple songs in the acoustic
guitar no we're actually planning on
asking like booking musicians like
hiring them being like hey we'll pay you
X you've come on and then some people
will just be guests on the show if
they're more politically minded and then
we'll jam and play songs are actually
talking about we we'll pay him like a
rate to come and play a studio band that
can cover like any song would be so
great cuz then we just do all sorts of
covers you do a cover and then you
instantly lose all monetization on the
on the show guys you you you have not
been listening to your own comments
about AI you don't need to hire any
musicians you don't need any bands you
don't need to pay anybody you could just
it all and move your hand like you're
strumming and your mouth just on camera
it looks like in fact you could be
singing well I I do I would just do it
but we could get bucko and or you know
maybe RB
rb3 he's looking healthy and rb3 is big
he's bigger than Roberto Jr yeah it's
Roberto beaks the third okay I was like
who's rb3 rb3 he's the new dude he's a
handsome
rooster all right Bas Jew says donate
this to the timcast X Miami Break Even
fund so so I I'll mention that a lot of
people super chated saying they didn't
realize that um oh did you see that
other one down there which one the other
one that the guy that mention I thought
I forgot where it was but it was
probably towards the bottom right
there's a bunch of people I don't know
which one you're referring to but
there's a bunch of people who are saying
like they didn't realize the stream on
YouTube was being ripped and taken from
our website and so uh and they're super
chatting the the general concept is it
is very very difficult to do Live Events
it is a tremendous amount of stress on
everyone it makes people have to work
extra hours and work double weekends so
it's basically Monday through Friday is
work then first thing Saturday and
Sunday you have to work then Monday
through Friday is the week of the event
with non-stop work 24 16 hours a day
because you are in you're in a different
city and you have to be working all the
time then Friday it's another 16 hours
then Saturday is tear down and travel
and then Sunday is return home and then
Monday is work again so that's two
weekends it is three straight weeks of
non-stop work to do an event yep what
we're looking at now is for uh we're
looking at Pittsburgh this is because
Pittsburg so close it's only about two
and a half to three hours away from us
we could literally just send out a crew
Friday morning set everything set up by
a production company and then we drive
in that that one day and it makes it one
day and then that Saturday we're back
and everything it's a lot easier to do
flying out requires us to build up a
temporary studio in the city and it's a
nightmarishly stressful thing yeah so
the issue was someone went on uh and
this is funny this is not a uh uh this
was not my understanding is that it was
not a like new member this was someone
who was actually donating a sub like a
larger sum of money ripped the show and
published it on YouTube for free spiking
it basically because we were trying to
do like hey a member to watch this it
costs a lot of money it was a lot of
work and we we sacrificed a lot for it
and then they basically spiked the show
and the issue is it's not so much about
the money it's about if we are not
making it work and we are losing money
from it I can't justify the level of
stress on the crew and the people
involved and I've already got some push
back saying we shouldn't I don't know if
we should we should keep doing this
maybe we'll just do it once a year or
something whereas I'm trying to be like
how do we make it once a month how do we
do smaller events on the East Coast we
can can drive to so we have once a month
a lot easier and I'm already getting
like hey man you probably shouldn't like
there's nothing we can do to stop people
from ripping the show and taking it and
we're we're going to keep losing money
and stressing people out no one's going
to want to do it and so it's like we'll
see what we can make happen I don't
think to be honest having like more
money come in changes the fact that
people are stressed out by this but I
got to be honest when after the show
like right when I got off stage they
like oh by the way 14,000 people are
watching live for free just basically
spiked the whole the whole membership
Drive thing you now have demoralization
and people being like we shouldn't break
our backs over this because we just got
spiked and it's like well okay but we'll
we'll try and figure it out like the
alternative is like do we have to
implement DRM on
timcast.net just it's it's it's it's
very it's very difficult to do yeah
we're looking at other ways of making it
uh feasible and that would be we're
actually looking like a bigger
conference doing like three days maybe
making bigger venues with multiple shows
because then it becomes something people
really want to be at still the ticket
sales are always going to be at that
level because it's just the only way you
can do it oh yeah like $1,000 for
three-day weekend or something like that
you yeah like it was it was I think it
was like 150 for Austin and we lost 20
or something thousand doing it and then
uh uh Miami was 175 and we only broke
even because Public Square sponsored the
show shout out Public Square you guys
rock thanks Michael uh yeah and so that
that sponsorship Bas basically made it
work if if not for that it would have
been like six figures lost doing the
event and uh it's it's a difficult thing
to do really hard I like the weekend
concept because the uh one of my
favorite parts of the event was meeting
people before and after the show and the
networking and that that was that was
like four hours on Saturday in the
afternoon if we were doing like a daily
we had a conference center like if we
did a conference Center Friday Saturday
Sunday and you could go hang out for 6
hours on Saturday have lunch meet tons
of people see them again Saturday night
see them again Sunday afternoon that
would be I think that' be really great
networking and and so the challenge is
that means but you'd be a th bucks a
ticket three weeks straight with no days
off yeah and it's not it's not just that
it's 16 hours a day every day right like
for me particularly and then for
everyone else like Carter went down and
back to like
Tuesday so he was for him it was even
more and then and then we had to fly out
surge like what twice yeah twice because
like it's it's it's it's a lot if we do
Pittsburgh it's like you might drive out
on Monday and check it out and then
drive back it's a single day much easier
that that'll be a lot easier yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah I mean it's smart that
you guys are are disclosing to people
how all this stuff works we get the same
thing with movies they're like dases you
should make 2,000 mules available for
free I'm like it cost me millions of
dollars to make this movie I've tapped
investors to do that I'm not even trying
to make them Rich over that I'm just
trying to give them their money back so
they'll give it back to me I do it again
this this is what I'm saying about the
left narrative over the idea of profit
is even prevalent on the right and the
Libertarians side like no no no we're
first of all I'll say this as
capitalists I reserve the right to
become wealthy off of a product I
produce that being said I am
ideologically driven what I want for
these events like when we lost money on
Austin I was like hey that's cool though
man we did something really
important we still need to be able to
keep doing it so I'm like break even you
know like we break even we're good but
when someone
goes on the website restreams it on
Twitch and YouTube and then we can't
make our money back you get people being
like why did like did we lose a bunch of
money on this and I'm like I think we we
theoretically could have lost between
like 100k and a million bucks based on
how this ripped us off because like
imagine this 14,000 people watching if
all 14,000 signed up at 10 bucks a month
you're looking at over a million bucks
in the year if they remain members for a
year now the reality is most people
would sign up for the month and then
cancel right away cuz they want to watch
watch one event that's a $10 ticket so
you're talking about 140 Grand at
minimum that that could have been made
and all of that money goes right back
into our events company that pays the
salary and the the ongoing costs of
running events we're trying to make so
we have a company that runs events that
we've created it has staff and we're
trying to make that company functional
for now it is losing money and I'm
putting my money into it to get it going
with the Miami event thanks to Public
Square we just about broke even but
understand that means I worked two extra
weekends and I didn't get I personally
in I I personally got nothing from it
yeah other than the way I describe it is
if I won the lottery and someone said
what would you buy with all that money
if you could buy anything what would you
I'd say win the culture War true that's
it so like that's that's it the
challenge is like the physical and
mental stress and then people noticed
this because I went on pbd Saturday
Saturday morning Patrick Bet David came
on and he did the event with us we're
entirely grateful he stole the show with
his great speech Standing Ovation and
they asked if I would do his show
Absolutely reciprocity and fresh and Fit
I made a promise I'd be on their show
but you could tell I was dead by the
time I was on Fresh dude fresh fit
hilarious cuz you're like staring off
while Luke's giv his intro thinking
about balers gate probably I was like
he's thinking about balers no my BR was
going I was like after two weeks of
non-stop work and sign this paper and
sign this paper and this one got
rejected now we had to get multiple
forms notorized to be able to do it like
the Florida government making us do tax
stuff by the time I'm there I'm just
like I'm just like seeing weird shapes
and there's like you know just
hallucinating there's so much that goes
into it and you guys remember if you pay
money towards us it gets better and then
it gets cooler and you can meet us and
stuff and blah blah blah it just gets
better it's the only thing that happens
we'll read some more we got Andrew Ling
lingel says I think you inspired meet
Kevin to do a timcast style YouTube live
Channel must have been all these super
chats giving him a good impression he
ain't timcast though or is he he's doing
I mean everybody's doing a live stream
though you know I do think it's funny
when I meet people and they're like hey
I'm doing a new live show but don't
worry it's not at 8:00 p.m. and I'm like
bro there's there's a million live
streams but there's a lot of people I
guess are worried
when we first started the show Crowder
was doing Thursday night live streams
and it was painfully obvious we'd get
like you know 50,000 50,000 50,000
37,000 50,000 and it was like when
Crowder came on a large portion went to
watch Crowder instead when Crowder
switch to morning shows we get a
consistent spike in viewership so I
think a lot of people are just like
what's the point of launching a live
show at the same time as IRL when it's
just like people are going to leave my
show to watch that but you just got to
do your thing you don't got to you're
like look Tucker Carlson goes on at the
same time he used to be on at the same
time as us it is what it is some people
choose to watch it they
don't all right here we go fix bayet
says 2,000 muls was awesome will you
look into Obama's Chef buck buck for
Miami I mean this is a case where I mean
for for a while there we were getting
the kind of Clinton Body Count of all
the people mysteriously dropping Dead
who had some questionable association
with the clintons and now with Obama
we've got these and and I haven't really
really looked very closely at all this
but there's been a guy on social media
who keeps releasing documents police
reports and things ma basically making
the things seem really pretty fishy and
and and and leaving the idea that that
the Obamas might have had something to
do with this now I will say I do think
Obama is to this day the most protected
man in America even more than Biden
because even with Biden you get the
impression that the left is sort of
their view on him is listen as long as
you're willing to sit in the canoe and
do your part uh we'll Row The Boat for
you but it there's a little bit of a
conditionality there if things get out
of hand and if somehow there's a Smoking
Gun and you got the Chinese money going
right it says Joe Biden on the check you
know we're out of here uh but with Obama
it's almost like no we have a pact we
will protect you no matter what you're
America's first black president we
cannot so the level of protection of
that guy is is unbelievable Ugly Truth
says Hamas fighting Israel is like
throwing a rock at a tank this was their
only way to make a statement wow so they
went and killed civilians and kidnapped
them to make a statement the funny thing
is I already stated this if Hamas broke
the fence down land landed with
paragliders in the music festival
rounded up all the civilians and said
everyone make it back to your cars now
before the conflict starts we don't want
civilians here we are we there's a
military operation go go go go go no and
started Fanning people to their cars and
all the civilians drove out and left
they went to the porta potties and
knocked and said a military operation is
underway I we need civilians to leave
now now now went to the kabut and says
everyone remain calm stay in your homes
we're not going to be entering your
homes that's sending a message
paragliding in and ushering civilians
out and asserting military control over
an area without harming anybody is a
message killing civilians is you call
that a message they're basically saying
we want to lose this conflict and we
want everyone to hate our guts Israel's
messages we will minimize civilian
casualties but we must stop the the we
must Target these military bases and
these weapons Depot I don't think that
they have a minimized civilian casualty
Israel outright says they have the do
I'm not saying that they follow it I'm
saying Israel's PR strategy is to in
every way say we seek to minimize
civilian casualties hamas's strategy is
to outright parade videos of them
holding children hostages like it's it's
it's it's just that if I mean I think
for the Israelis it's not only the moral
thing to do but it's actually The
Prudent thing to do because there are
all these International organizations
that are actually waiting to pounce on
Israel they're just waiting to be able
to show that there is a moral
equivalence between what the Israelis
are doing and what the Hamas guys are
doing that's the that's the next shoe to
drop and so the Israelis to the degree
they can have got to be really careful
to say we are hitting military targets
there might be some civilian casualties
but we're not aiming at the civilians
they just announced they were going to
for the people in Northern Gaza to
evacuate to the South and then uh people
like please don't start a ground
Invasion the Americans were like we are
officially requesting that you do not
start the ground Invasion the un's like
do not start a ground Invasion right now
because I agree if the Israelis go in
there and start massacring women and
kids and kids on their bikes the whole
world's going to going to go to war with
them it's War they're going to do it
well then the whole world's going to
attack them they got to know that uh
well not the whole world half the world
I I it could be World War II it's but
but this if they go if they go slaughter
a million people dude what that's like
Nazi level stuff what doesn't here's
what doesn't matter right Israel knows
who their allies are and they need only
convince moderate leaning Allied Nations
Russia is not going to align itself with
Israel Iran is not going to align with
Israel if Hamas went in and Hamas
literally went and killed civilians and
Iran is still defending Palestine it
doesn't matter if Israel goes in and
start Israel right now is bombing Gaza
and the West will still def defend
Israel and Eastern Nations will still
defend the Palestinians in Gaza my
concern is I don't think you can defend
against drone swarms and nuclear weap
you can kind of blow them up in the sky
but it's one of those things where like
all the attackers are the ones that are
going to win like the Defenders are all
going to get destroyed uh Maybe not
maybe it's hyperbolic but it's like a
war where like only offense offense
offense offense so I think yeah what you
say I was just going to say that I think
the reason that Netanyahu is very
careful to sort of insist that this is a
declaration of war is because when you
War you remove the old logic of
proportionality the logic of
proportionality is your tribe came over
to my tribe and killed 10 people so I'm
only allowed now to come to your tribe
and kill 10 people I can't come and kill
a 100 people because that's
disproportionate to what you did right
but think of the Pearl Harbor example
the Japanese attack Us in Pearl Harbor
we didn't say okay well there were 8,000
people killed at Pearl Harbor we're
going to make sure we kill 8,000 but no
more than 8,000 Japanese we were like
okay you did this it's an act of war and
now all bets are off that's kind of what
the Israelis are saying let's read this
one from take video he says Tim plays
civilization peacefully on Prince
difficulty but on Immortal or deity or
in PvP you would lose without violence I
don't know if this reflects real life uh
incorrect but close I play on King
difficulty uh whenever I play games like
even balers gate I always just play the
middle and so uh I actually I was like
Prince difficulty it's been a long time
since I played Civ 2 but no like King
was the middle of the road like
normalized One MH I'm pretty sure and
then the rest were like easy to hard but
Immortal or ority I think you are
correct but those are like overly
aggressive where they give military
bonuses to the AI and stuff like that
PVP you're correct about but when I play
Civilization I didn't say that I was
just peacefully minding M business for
the most part what I said was I would
focus on developing my country's
technology to become Superior and then
anyone who came at me would get Stamped
Out or crushed immediately but but I was
I was never the aggressor it was always
like I'm minding my own business leave
me the F alone and then as soon as I
tried to attack I just and then one
thing I really loved doing was if I was
playing peacefully and minding my own
business and civilization too and then
for some reason just like an opposing
Nation decided to just come down on me I
would just cheat give myself one nuke
and then blow up one of their cities and
be like back to mining my own business I
am God here don't you come at me France
I have found that on the hardest
difficulty you have to go to war in that
game often yeah well you don't get a
choice I mean it's it's it's a it's an
amazing video game when when you have a
nation and another country says uh uh in
the more modern uh uh the later civil I
think what C Civ six yeah I think I
played five I don't know if I played six
but if you have uranium in your country
and oil and other countries don't you
have nukes and they don't they are going
to send a ground Invasion to try and
take that uranium from you you're at
warb whether you want to want to be or
not all right where we
at zos says the 2003 East Coast power
outage was an accident from a fighter
jet equipped with a weapon to shut down
grids all our enemies know this is that
true I never heard that that's a new one
yeah never heard that one
before well let's read some more then I
suppose I don't know if somebody Weston
Kramer says the people who voted for
these policies in these cities are like
the peasant and Monty Python help help
I'm being oppressed it was repressed
help help I'm being repressed repressed
yeah that was really really funny that
was one of the best scenes ever they're
like he's like where's your king and
they're like we don't have a king aarco
communist syndic aarco syndicalist
commun or something like that they're so
ahead of their time you don't realize
years later no no he's like I am your
king and they're like I don't remember
voting for you so he's like we don't
vote for a king through he the lady in
the lake gave me a sword and declared
that I King arth like a lady a wet what
what do you say like a a woman handing
Distributing swords is no basis for a
system of govern so good my favorite was
name one thing that the Romans gave us
that doesn't long pause
roads apart from roads name one thing
that the Romans gave us laws apart from
roads and
laws it's really amazing how how how
great they were yeah and where they are
today South Park is doing a special I
was just going to bring where they race
and gender swapped the main characters
hilarious Cartman's a black woman now
it's good is that is that supposed to be
released I haven't actually seen my
sister sent me today uh oh it's out well
she sent me the preview it that's what
I've see I'm not sure when it's coming a
watery tart was the the witch apparently
the woman that gave him the sword was a
watery tart that was the line you're
looking for in money python all right
angry marsupio says at Gettysburg breach
loaders only figured into the first day
when buford's Cavalry held off a 3X
force due to fire superiority infantry
was issued muzzle loaders on both sides
tactics and numbers one yes that is true
um I watch you go to Gettysburg it's
amazing Gettysburg is like 40 minutes
away from here and it is just one of not
only is there awesome food there but
there's tons of haunted houses oh great
chocolate choces or whatever uh
Gettysburg is a lot of fun yeah you know
go there and learn your history and I
went we went to like a couple little
like antique stores and they have real
cannonballs and they have a whole bunch
of antique weapons wow old quarters
where where doctors would amputate legs
and the blood was seeping through the
floors I mean it is very haunting and
and and it brings the reality of
Gettysburg it's amazing I think the
crazy thing is that they had repeaters
during the Civil War but they weren't
spread but man could you imagine being
being commissioned a repeater it's like
I I think they loaded through the
through the uh um through the stock cuz
I cuz I went to the Antique store and
they had a bunch and they like the back
opens and you push them in the back and
then and then you lever action yeah man
what were those uh what was it uh
Henry what was the company that did that
the repeater was I think I want to say
CT that that's a that's a revolver yeah
look at up first repeating rifle so one
yeah yeah I think it's repeating Spencer
it was a spenc Spencer repeating rifle
was that the first one no Winchester
Winchester repeater Winchester
yeah say that but I like yeah true true
yeah I have a repeater he made
improvements to the Henry
Rifle right that's all right okay was it
was it the Henry Repeater I suppose so
I'm not sure how far back I think the
Improvement Winchester made was a little
lever action with the hand lever action
what was the Henry then I beats me man
you know what I really don't like the
tube mags I like the the side load where
you push him in there's like a
spring-loaded little lch and you push
them in the side cuz the uh uh the tube
mag it's you can't so I got a 3030
repeater and it's like you can't get the
the the you can't get to close it's
super annoying MH but anyway we'll grab
a couple more Super
chats all right what do we have Brett
ain't dead says Terminator epic 2001 A
Space Odyssey life-changing everyone
should watch and contemplate man's
Origins and future truly ahead of its
time very
cool seriously says science fiction
becomes science fact and it's probably
going to be C more like crazier than we
even realize Jeff summer says big fan of
timcast love you guys Ian I got to say
you pray through Jesus to God the only
way to the father is through the son
read the Bible start with the Gospel of
John it was written for the new
Believers and those who don't know any
way love you brother oh thanks man I got
to say watching the passion was
fascinating because I never watched it
until a few months ago and uh the
politics of the story is what I found
truly fascinating I mean for a lot of
people I'm sure it's like divine
inspiration you're watching the story of
the Christ but watching the politics of
you know Rome and the the Jewish leaders
and the followers of of Christ it's fasc
it's a fascinating political story yeah
yeah have you seen also you should watch
it the the riveting thing about this is
also the historicity if you um only in
the last few years has there now been
archaeological evidence Medallion
evidence Stones validating not only the
Hebrew scriptures but the Christian
scriptures so for example Pontius pilot
until about a few years ago Pontius
pilot was not believed to be a
historical person there was no really no
existing record of anyone named pontious
pilot in any of the annals of histories
that have come down and then they dig up
a stone and right on there it says
Pontius pilot the exact words and people
are like whoa you know and right now in
Israel they're digging up a a large pool
called the pool of salom now this is the
pool where the Jews bathed ritually
before walking to the temple so think
about it this large pool which is an
olympic sized swimming pool
basically Jesus of Nazareth would have
had to have bathed in that pool because
we know that he went to the temple and
walked that exact Road and this is not
again a matter of probability they
debate where did the crucifixion occur
over here did occur over there all right
but there's certain facts that are
coming out to light that are now
absolutely indisputable right and uh and
it's it's a very eerie experience to be
in Jerusalem right now wow all right
everybody if you haven't already please
smash that like button and subscribe to
this channel become a member at
timcast.net
server you download the app you sign in
they're going to be hosting their own
after show they're going to be hanging
out they do pre-shows they do after
shows so if you want to keep the
conversation going and hang out with
like-minded individuals become a member
at
timcast.net shout anything out like to
just do another plug for the movie uh
policestate fm.net uh go to the theater
if you can October 23rd to 25th and um
really fun to see it with like-minded
people just like you were just saying or
if you want to watch it home Friday
October 27th is the virtual premiere
full screening of the film live Q&A with
Dan Bonino and me to follow and all for
the price of a movie ticket but the
One-Stop shop to get tickets you can get
them from Fandango go to policestate
fm.net buy your tickets there
Carter Banks we got a lot of uh music
stuff coming up today I put some
finishing touches on a secret song we
will have stuff on um Fridays coming
soon um but yeah follow timcast songs on
YouTube at timcast songs trash House
Records if you want to follow me
personally you can uh follow me at
Carter banks on Twitter and Carter banks
forl on uh Instagram I'm Ian Crossland
you guys follow me anywhere on the
internet at Ian Crossland uh I think I'm
going to go on the Discord later so I'm
going to meet up with everybody behind
the scenes let's get down let's talk
probably about 10:30 Raymond g Stanley I
see you out there I'll connect with you
later and then I'll I'll be jumping in
about 10:30 and I'll probably only be on
for a half hour I got to get up early
which means if if you want to yell at
Ian or Praise Him become a member at
timcast.net
you guys are going to like it we did all
the cameras and the mics and stuff ready
to go just need to wait for the right
time basically well I mean uh maybe even
next week the the issue is right now
it's like we want to do it right so I
want to have a good kickoff and uh get
like an actual group to do an acoustic
set right and then uh we'll figure it
out but I don't think it'll be every
weekend it'll be when possible yeah
exactly it's not just going to be like
me or Ian just jamming but we want to
get like real musicians and artists like
not that we're not but we're just not
practiced well practiced musician I mean
we want we want to make it a show we
want it to be like hey we have an
acoustic performance from insert band
not just oh Tim and are jamming again
it's getting to the point where we could
just go live anytime if it's that's
awesome and then what we're going to do
is we're going to put the clips from IRL
of the music performances on The timcast
Music Channel yeah that'll be sweet so
it'll all be there uh yeah but I'm
surge.com pleasure meeting you denesh my
mom's a big fan and uh I will see you
guys on the next one we will see you all
Monday thanks for hanging
out